this episode is brought to you by levels
very excited about this one i wrote
about the health benefits of using
continuous glucose monitors cgm's more
than 10 years ago in the four hour body
and at that time cgms were horribly
primitive and hard to use super painful
levels has now made this technology and
the insights that come from it easy and
available to everyone putting in the
sensors everything about it is smooth
easy i found it completely painless and
i started tracking my glucose way back
in the day to learn more about what i
should and shouldn't be eating keeping
my blood sugar stable is critical to my
daily and long-term health and
performance goals with levels you can
see how different foods affect your
health with real-time feedback poor
glucose control which you don't want is
associated with a number of chronic
conditions not just diabetes but also
alzheimer's and heart disease it can
impact your mood certainly affects my
mood energy levels right that work in
the afternoon that dip that you feel for
instance that's just one example and
weight management and we all respond
differently sometimes a little bit
sometimes vastly differently even to the
same foods so one type of carbohydrate
that my body might process well let's
say that's fruit or rice or sweet potato
your body might not the levels app
interprets your glucose data and
provides a simple score after you eat a
meal so you can see how different foods
affect you and then develop a
personalized diet that's right for you
and your goals seeing this data in real
time at least for me and for so many
others who use levels is a really
powerful behavioral change mechanism and
many of the guests on the podcast have
talked about this marco kenora famous
chef used levels to determine that say
walking for him just a few hundred steps
after a meal significantly affected his
glucose levels levels is backed by a
world-class team and group of advisors
including names you've likely heard
before including repeat podcast guest dr
dom d'agostino and many others if you're
interested in learning more about levels
and trying a cgm yourself
learn all about it go to levels dot link
slash tim that's levels dot link slash
tim i'll spell it out l e v e l s dot
l i n k slash tim check them out today
i highly encourage you to consider
getting this data on your own personal
responses to the food that you eat the
food that maybe you shouldn't eat the
food that you might want to eat more of
all of these things you can learn and
that is at levels dot link slash tim you
can also find the link in this episode's
description
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt
what on earth is element it is a
delicious sugar-free electrolyte drink
mix i've stocked up on boxes and boxes
of this it was one of the first things
that i bought when i saw covid coming
down the pike and i usually use one to
two per day element is formulated to
help anyone with their electrolyte needs
and perfectly suited to folks following
a keto low carb or paleo diet or if you
drink a ton of water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise mountain biking et
cetera another application if you've
ever struggled to feel good on keto low
carb or paleo it's most likely because
even if you're consciously consuming
electrolytes you're just not getting
enough and it relates to a bunch of
stuff like a hormone called aldosterone
blah blah blah when insulin is low but
suffice to say this is where element
again spelled lmnt can help my favorite
flavor by far is citrus salt which is a
side note you can also use to make a
kick ass no sugar margarita but for
special occasions obviously you're
probably already familiar with one of
the names behind it rob wolf r-o-b-b rob
wolf who is a former research biochemist
and two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch that's how it got started his
brazilian jiu jitsu coaches turned him
onto electrolytes as a performance
enhancer things clicked and bam company
was born so if you're on a low carb diet
or fasting electrolytes play a key role
in relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring all that's garbage
unneeded there's none of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be by one of my favorite
athlete friends three navy seal teams as
prescribed by their master chief marine
units fbi sniper teams at least five nfl
teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it element will give you your money
back no questions asked they have
extremely low return rates for a limited
time you can get a free element sample
pack with any purchase it's the perfect
way to try all of their flavors or if
you're feeling generous sharing with a
friend who might enjoy this special
offer is available here at this link
drink lmnt.com
tim that's drink element again drink
lmnt.com
tim optimal
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today is dr matt caberline
you can find him on twitter m kaberline
let me spell that for you
k-a-e-b-e-r-l-e-i-n
and matt is a professor of laboratory
medicine and pathology at the university
of washington school of medicine with
adjunct appointments in genome sciences
and oral health sciences dr caberline's
research interests are focused on
understanding biological mechanisms of
aging in order to facilitate
translational interventions that promote
health span and improve quality of life
for people and companion animals
dr caberline is the founding director of
the university of washington healthy
aging and longevity research institute
the director of the nih nathan shock
center of excellence in the basic
biology of aging at university of
washington director of the biological
mechanisms of healthy aging training
program and founder and co-director of
the dog aging project you can find him
online at caberlinelab.org
again on twitter
mkaberline and we will link to all the
other social linkedin etc in the show
notes at tim.log slash podcast matt
welcome to the show thanks tim it's a
thrill to be here i am
very excited to dive in we will run out
of time probably before we run out of
topics
but
let's just start
at the basic of basics and
get a definition of aging biology first
of all i think that's actually
perhaps the hardest question you're
going to ask me today because there is
really a lack of consensus i would say
is first of all what do we mean when we
talk about aging and then in particular
aging biology but i'll take the simple
part of that i hope and so what i think
of when i think of aging biology is
the
biological physiological changes that
occur
as
animals organisms age and i think the
important point to appreciate i think
everybody recognizes that biologically
we are different when we are old
compared to when we are young nobody
would argue with that i think what's
important to appreciate is that there
are
characteristic changes that happen in
all people as we age and some of those
changes
happen in other animals even into very
simple single-celled organisms and so
when i think about the biology of aging
i think about it at different levels you
can think about the molecular changes
that go along with aging you can think
about the functional changes that go
along with aging you can think about the
behavioral changes that go along with
aging but those are all driven by the
biology of aging and of course
the last point i'll make is that
most of the major causes of death and
disability and functional decline that
we experience
are due to the biology of aging so if
you look at all of the major killers
well almost all of the major killers in
developed countries they all share a
single greatest risk factor and it's how
old you are and that's because of the
underlying biology that creates a change
in our physiology that is permissive for
all of those diseases to happen
where did your
research begin in this area
i actually got started thinking about
and actively studying the biology of
aging as a graduate student so this was
back in i guess it was 1998 i was a
first year graduate student at mit
and i went to mit thinking i was going
to do structural biology x-ray
crystallography something like that and
i heard a talk by a professor there
lenny guarente on the research that his
lab had started doing really only a few
years before i got there where they were
taking a genetic molecular biology
approach to try to understand the
mechanisms of aging and at that time
they were working in a single-celled
organism budding yeast called
saccharomyces cerevisiae but to this day
i still don't know why that resonated
with me but i have this very vivid
memory of sitting in this lecture hall
hearing lenny talk about
trying to understand the mechanisms of
aging using genetics and molecular
biology and biochemistry and i was
hooked i never
ever thought about studying something as
complicated as aging and it it just it
captured me and so i went and i talked
to lenny and i ended up joining his lab
and i've been working on this problem
you know in one way shape or form since
then now you at one point seem to have
had a fork in the road mathematics we
were talking about this before
we started recording
and biology
did you have any misgivings about
veering into the
sphere of biology
so i don't think i ever had any
misgivings but first of all i'll say
i've had many forks in the road and
honestly at that age and maybe to some
extent still in my life if anything i
under analyze decisions so i don't think
i had any misgivings so what i'll say is
i got my undergraduate degree at a
college called western washington
university which is about 90 miles north
of seattle so it's a smaller
university mostly undergrads no phd
students maybe a few masters students
and i went there
intending to major in biochemistry and
it was
probably the first summer there i had a
math professor who was fantastic who
kind of pulled me aside
and you know he was like you're really
good at math i think you should take my
proofs class over the summer and and i'd
never actually done a formal
mathematical proof before that but i
ended up taking the class loving it and
then he's like you should major in math
so i ended up getting a degree in
mathematics and a degree in biochemistry
when i graduated from my undergrad but i
don't think i ever seriously thought
about a career in mathematics i think
you know i do wonder sometimes what
would have been different if i'd gone
down that road but i think i was always
drawn
towards
biology
in some shape biomedical research i
think i wanted to have an impact on
human health not that you can't have an
impact in lots of other fields but i
think i was drawn to that and so i never
really seriously considered applying to
graduate school in a mathematical
application and only applied to
biology biochemistry i did apply to one
chemistry program as well let's flash
forward to current day we're going to do
a lot of this bouncing around you're
wearing a shirt it says dog aging
project on it
what is the dog aging project so the dog
aging project is
the largest
study longitudinal study of aging in i
think any animal but it's all in
companion dogs and so this is a
national study across the united states
now of more than 40 000 companion dogs
living with their owners when i say
companion dogs i mean pet dogs living
with their owners to really try to
understand
what are the most important genetic and
environmental factors that influence
aging biological aging in dogs
with the recognition that most of the
mechanisms of aging that happen in dogs
also happen in people and so this will
be relevant
for both companion dogs and also for
people and i would say there are really
two parts to the dog aging project the
first part which is the largest is what
we call a longitudinal study of aging so
completely observational
all of the dogs that are in the
longitudinal component we're not asking
the owners to do anything different than
they normally would we are
following those dogs over time to try to
learn as much as we can about what are
the factors that cause them to age the
way they do develop diseases that they
do as they get older and then there's a
much smaller clinical trial which is
really aimed at testing whether or not
we can
have an impact on the biological aging
process in companion dogs to slow aging
maybe even reverse functionally some
aspects of aging help dogs live longer
healthier lives and we're testing a drug
called rapamycin which i'm sure we'll
talk more about in that clinical trial i
kind of think of this as having two
parts a longitudinal study is let's
understand as much as we can about aging
the clinical trial is let's do something
about it and i am very much
in the camp of let's do something about
it
yes we will talk quite a bit more about
rapamycin maybe very soon in this
conversation
and
for people listening my hope and
intention with this conversation is to
help listeners to
better develop
scientific literacy to the extent that
you can separate some
fact from fiction
with respect to longevity
life span and
health span so let's underline this word
healthspan for a moment
and i'm going to front load this so
please forgive me i was planning on
maybe asking this later
could you please describe your
experience with frozen shoulder
sure so should i define health span
first or do you want to come back to
that later well i thought they might
they might tie in so however you would
like to
tackle it so the first thing i would say
is it's interesting because this term
health span is pretty new even in my
field 10 years ago most people were
talking about health span and i think
it's sort of become popular because it
resonates with people and what we mean
by healthspan
is
the period of your life that is spent in
what we would consider good health and i
think there are different ways you could
define that and maybe different people
would define good health slightly
differently but conceptually i think
this makes a lot of sense right we all
know we go through
our lives for most people when you're
young you are experiencing good health
you are functioning well and as you get
older that health declined that function
declines you know i often will say that
that i am damaged 51 year old and what i
mean by that is that functionally i'm in
pretty good health for being 51 but
functionally i'm i'm nowhere near where
i was when i was 21 and i think we all
experienced that so healthspan is a
concept to try to track how much of your
life is spent in good health now the
reason why i'm going into a little bit
of detail on this is i think it's really
important to recognize that healthspan
is not quantitative we don't have a way
to quantitatively measure health span in
some ways it's you know you you know it
when you see it kind of thing or when
you don't so i want to make sure that
people don't get confused about
when claims are made that drug x extends
health span
you have to be a little bit careful
because if it's something you can't
quantify you really shouldn't make a
claim that you have changed it
scientifically so i think that's
important okay so frozen shoulder how
does that come into play so when i was i
was probably
47 or 48 i started having a lot of pain
in my shoulder and you know i'm i'm
pretty active i do resistance training
fairly regularly i play softball when
it's softball season and played
basketball
stuff like that
so it was a gradual thing where i
noticed that i was having more and more
pain in my right shoulder and i really
noticed it during softball season but it
was a weird like i've had injuries here
and there but it was a weird kind of
pain where you know if i was in the gym
trying to do a bench press or something
like that the pain was most severe when
i started and then it kind of gradually
got better as i as i was going i'd never
really had an injury like that before i
had no idea what it was i'd never heard
a frozen shoulder at this point but when
it really impacted my health span or at
least i would say my quality of life was
one day when my son and i went across
the street to the park near our house
and i tried throwing the football to him
and i just couldn't do it i did like two
throws and i had to tell my kid
you know jace i'm really sorry i just
can't do it it hurts too much and for me
i mean i think you know obviously
we all have life experiences and many
people have had experiences that were
worse than that for sure but for me that
was kind of an emotional moment i was at
a point in my life where i had a
physical
problem and i couldn't go out and throw
a ball with my kid and i'll also say i'm
trying to get better at this but i'm
a somewhat stereotypical guy and that i
won't go to the doctor until i have to
go to the doctor
so that was the moment where i finally
was like okay i have to get this fixed
so i went to my
general practitioner he wanted me to go
to physical therapy i went to physical
therapy for i don't know maybe six seven
weeks and it was just making things
worse so i went back to him and i at
this time i thought i had a torn rotator
cuff like i had convinced myself that
that's what was wrong so i went back to
him and i'm like physical therapy is not
helping get me in to see a specialist i
need to get this fixed and i was
actually hoping that i would go to the
specialist he would say okay you have a
torn rotator cuff we need to get you to
have surgery because again i just wanted
it done i wanted it fixed so finally i
go to see the specialist and within five
minutes he's like you don't have a torn
rotator cuff you have
frozen shoulder and he called it
adhesive capsulitis which again i hadn't
heard of before and he explained to me
that it's fairly common in people in my
sort of demographic group more common in
women than men but but it happens in
lots of men and it's an inflammation of
the shoulder capsule
his recommendation was he said i can
give you a shot but i don't recommend it
it doesn't really last that long and
that can create problems with the
cartilage like a corticosteroid exactly
yeah so i think you should just go back
to physical therapy and you know for
some people it goes away in about a year
and that was not what i wanted to hear
right
it was like
yeah a year that's not why i came back
exactly so i was pretty depressed
shortly i don't i this is another part
of my personal makeup i think i don't
stay depressed but i was pretty for me i
was pretty depressed right after this
and i vividly remember and i was angry
too and i'm sitting in the car just like
this sucks
and i'm thinking to myself okay you know
this is an age-related
inflammatory condition this is exactly
what i study it probably should have
occurred to me before then but i finally
had that realization
and so then i thought to myself well i
know
some things that might help and so maybe
i can treat myself and that's what i
ended up doing so again sure we'll talk
more about rapamycin but that's the drug
that i if i had to pick one intervention
that's the one that i have focused on
the most throughout my career and one of
the things rapamycin is quite good at is
reducing
age-related sterile inflammation and so
i thought maybe this would be a case
where rapamycin would be helpful so i
started taking rapamycin about two weeks
in i was pretty convinced that it was
having an effect because i got about i'd
say half my range of motion back and by
the end of the 10 weeks so i decided i
was going to try 10 weeks and we can
talk about that why 10 weeks if you want
to but that's sort of what i what i had
decided by the end of the 10 weeks i was
back
the pain was gone and i had probably 90
percent of range of motion back and it
hasn't come back so look i'm a scientist
i believe in placebo effect it is real
this was so painful and for me so
limiting on what i could do i just i
don't think it was placebo effect i
think it probably was the rapamycin so
let's talk
a lot more about rapamycin what is
rapamyce let's begin with the
primary or initial indication for which
it is used or maybe we don't want to
start there but let's just broadly
explain what rapamycin is and now also
just for a definition of terms you said
sterile inflammation does that simply
refer to a chronic inflammation
not caused by infection that's right
yeah and actually i think maybe that's
worth digressing on for just a minute
because i think you know a lot of times
you'll hear
people say that our immune system
declines with age and i'm sure we've all
heard that during covet right we know
that the elderly were most susceptible
to severe outcomes from covet so you'll
hear people say that that's actually not
true it's not
correct that's half the story so the
ability of our immune system to respond
to pathogens declines with age or to
respond to a vaccine declines with age
at the same time our immune system is
responding inappropriately to a bunch of
stuff that it shouldn't be responding to
that's the sterile inflammation that i'm
referring to and you could broadly group
that as autoimmunity there are a lot of
disorders that we all know about that
are sort of formal autoimmune disorders
but i think a lot of the
chronic aches and pains that go along
with aging are a milder form of
autoimmunity that are driven by this
sterile inflammation that there's also a
term that has been popularized in the
field called inflammating inflammation
to refer to this increase in sterile
inflammation that goes along with aging
but i do think this is it's an important
point immune function
both declines and increases so it's
responding to stuff it shouldn't be
responding to and it stops doing its job
the way that it's supposed to and those
two things are connected
part of the reason why our immune system
can't respond to things like coronavirus
or a coronavirus vaccine is because it's
spending too much time
doing this autoimmune stuff and that
inhibits the response that you want so
rapamycin it turns out is pretty potent
it seems at blunting that
sterile inflammation it may also have
impacts on
the
response of the immune system to
pathogens and we can talk more about
that that's one of the concerns that
people have with rapamycin but it seems
quite potent to turning down this
sterile inflammation and what's been
seen in mice for sure and there's some
evidence for this in people as well is
that if you give six weeks of rapamycin
to a mouse you can actually and then you
stop the treatment you can actually
cause that aged immune system to
function like a young immune system and
it fully responds to a vaccine whereas
the aged immune system that's never seen
rapamycin doesn't respond to a vaccine
what
and i'm going to ask a lot of basic
questions in part because on one hand i
probably don't know the answers and then
i'll also act as a stand-in for the
audience
what exactly or even approximately
happens even if it's
theory at this point
to someone as they age that causes this
let's just say double-edged sword with
immune system changes where on one hand
they're under-reacting
but they're under-reacting
in a sense because they're overreacting
somewhere else
what are the processes responsible for
that so i will give you kind of what we
think right now i will say it's not
fully known and i'll also make a
disclaimer i am not an immunologist i
have tried several times to learn enough
immunology to be credible and i failed
miserably every time it's like a
completely different language i have a
lot of respect for immunologists but i
really wish they'd learn how to talk to
regular scientists let alone regular
people
[Applause]
but uh but i'll give you my
understanding of the immunology here so
so there's probably a couple of things
going on one is that you know we are
from birth constantly exposed to all
sorts of stuff that our immune system
reacts to right all sorts of pathogens
and even things that aren't necessarily
pathogens our immune system will respond
to i think part of it is just the
burden of that
years and years and years of the immune
system responding to all sorts of
different
stimuli
that it
becomes overactive towards even self
antigens right and that's where the
autoimmunity comes in i think from the
context of aging biology the mechanism
that has been best worked out is in the
area of what are called senescent cells
so these are
cells that accumulate as we age they
don't die so there's a there's a
mechanism called apoptosis or some
people say apoptosis where cells can
undergo program death or
death in response to damage and that's
an anti-cancer mechanism right you want
if cells are damaged you want them to
die
so they don't become cancer
senescent cells are a different off-ramp
that damaged cells can take they don't
die so they stay around but they stop
dividing and so they won't become cancer
the problem with senescent cells is that
they give off a whole bunch of signals
that hyperactivate the immune system or
target the immune system these are
called inflammatory cytokines it's a
process called the sasp sasp or
senescence associated secretory
phenotype these are all these signals
the senescent cells that accumulate as
we get older there's more and more of
them as we get older they give off these
signals which tell the immune system to
go crazy basically and so that probably
from a molecular viewpoint is i think
most people would say
maybe the primary reason why we have
this chronic inflammation with age
and there are strategies people are
taking there are these class of
molecules called synalytics which are
molecules that are designed to go kill
senescent cells right with the idea that
lessening senescent cells like
anxiolytic this
is that the basic
idea yeah well right so the idea is
with age right we have this accumulation
of senescent cells they don't seem as
far as we know they're not doing
anything good so if we can target
molecules that will specifically kill
those cells that'll be
beneficial and the mechanisms are
complicated probably beyond probably
beyond the detail that we want to get
into here and i mean this this idea has
caught fire in the field right it's a
really sexy idea right we've got these
misbehaving cells they're good for
nothing do nothing cells that just kind
of hang out and convince the other cells
to do bad stuff so if we could get rid
of them that'd be a good thing turns out
it's probably not that easy not
surprisingly biology is always more
complicated but
conceptually it's a really nice idea and
so lots of people are working on this
now this ties back to rapamycin because
what rapamycin does it doesn't kill the
senescent cells but it basically shuts
off
this sasp the inflammatory signals so
it's like you're not killing the good
for nothings that are creating the
trouble or you're just putting a gag on
them they can't talk anymore and
rapamycin seems really potent at doing
that
and then one of the consequences of that
is it seems to reboot the immune system
and then the immune system is actually
pretty good at clearing senescent cells
so it may actually indirectly also help
clear senescent cells so that's a little
bit speculative that's kind of my own
personal idea that there's some evidence
for and i think you know if i'm right
which
i
sometimes
then we'll get more data for that but it
makes it makes sense but but definitely
lots and lots of people have shown that
rapamycin can turn off the inflammatory
signals that the senescent cells are
putting out
so that was my rationale for the whole
going back to the frozen shoulder i sort
of had you know i did enough reading on
on what it was to recognize that it was
inflammation of the shoulder capsule not
knowing why some people get it and some
people don't but it made sense to me
that it was tied into this chronic
inflammatory state
and we had already at that time data
from my lab that in mice we could knock
down that chronic inflammation in a few
different tissues with rapamycin very
potently and so i thought there's a
chance it might work why not better than
waiting a year yeah i mean one of the
best i've made a lot of bad decisions in
my life fortunately not too many really
bad ones but that was a good one and i
mean again this this gets back to what
you were
how we originally got on this which is
this idea of health span i think that
we are
sort of trained at least as scientists
and medical professionals to think of
health only in the context of disease
right but i would say most people
their decline in health as they get
older starts way before they are ever
diagnosed with kidney disease or heart
disease or emphysema or whatever right
pick your favorite age-related disease
we all have these chronic aches and
pains and declines in function that have
a real impact on our quality of life and
so i think those are maybe
as important maybe more important than
the individual diseases that could be
impacted by targeting this biology of
aging so rapamycin just to double click
on that word for a quick second and you
can please correct me if i get this
wrong but for those people interested in
more we will talk
additionally about rapamycin in this
conversation but had a conversation on
easter island also known as rapid i'm
jealous that's on my bucket list years
and years ago with a number of
scientists as well as dr peter tia who
made the introduction between us so if
you want to learn more about the origin
story of rapamycin certainly you can
listen to that conversation
what is rapamycin most commonly used for
these days
rapamycin was first approved by the fda
i think in 1999 so it's been clinically
used for a while now to prevent organ
transplant rejection and i think it was
first in kidney transplant patients but
it is used for some other transplants as
well so that's how it's been used
most in
clinical practice it is also used for
some some types of cancer are
particularly responsive to rapamycin
there are a few more rare disorders that
are
known to be caused by hyperactivation of
mtor which we haven't talked about yet
but mtor is the protein that rapamycin
inhibits and so it's used clinically
there it's also used in or has been used
in cardiac stents to prevent regrowth of
cells over the stems so
mostly organ transplant but a few other
less widely known uses i was working
because we may or may not know someone
who has emptor on his license plate
how many times do you think
the term mtor has been uttered on the
drive the podcast that peter diaz hosts
i mean it's gotta be in the thousands
yeah i was i was gonna say you know
somewhere between five and ten thousand
but that may be a low guess
why ten weeks to come back to your story
honestly that was based off of studies
that we and others have done in mice
where we know that
it seems like between 4 and 10 weeks or
12 weeks you can definitely get a lot of
benefits from rapamycin treatment it
might be worth at some point talking
about what those are it's pretty
striking how wide in terms of tissue
these these effects that people see are
pat let's let's use the power of now no
time like the present so the first thing
i would say is you know if you had asked
me
10 maybe 15 years ago
the interventions that we are studying
on the biology of aging how are they
going to work are they going to slow
aging or are they actually going to
potentially do more than just slow the
decline i would have said we're going to
slow the decline i didn't think that we
would be able to find things that could
actually
make
organs and tissues functionally better
but we know that's the case with
rapamycin and with some other
interventions so in mice if you treat
old mice with rapamycin for between four
and 12 weeks and i'm giving that's a
pretty big range but that's because
different people have done different
experimental paradigms you can
definitely see reversal of functional
declines
in the immune system so the immune
system will respond to vaccines better
after treatment with rapamycin the aged
immune system let me clarify that
in the heart so the aged heart functions
better after rapamycin treatment in the
oral cavity that's work from my lab that
was done by jonathan ahn when he was a
graduate student with me you can reverse
periodontal disease
eight weeks of rapamycin treatment
reverse periodontal disease what type of
periodontal disease so periodontal
disease keep your train of thought but
i'm curious so periodontal having just
gone to the dentist for the first time
in three years after covid right so in
people and again i'm not a dentist i
haven't spent as much time trying to
become a dentist
[Laughter]
my understanding is that in people
periodontal disease is usually diagnosed
by a few clinically defining features
the most important one is probably bone
loss around the teeth so we all have
bone around our teeth and in everybody
with age that recedes with age you lose
bone around the teeth gingival
inflammation so gingival inflammation
alone is gingivitis but that's one of
the features of periodontal disease and
then pathological changes in the oral
microbiome so those are the things that
we looked at in mice actually take a
step back the first thing we did was
just ask do mice develop periodontal
disease with age because people hadn't
done that previously and it turns out
they do they get those three
defining features of periodontal disease
and what we saw was that eight weeks of
treatment with rapamycin reverted the
oral microbiome back to something that
looks more like a youthful microbiome
dramatically reduced gingival
inflammation and actually re-grew bone
around the tissue that's wild yeah it's
amazing i'm going to keep interrupting
because
this this i want to hook on to it's so
interesting the regrowth
of
bone tissue do you think there's a
possibility that is a it is a
non-selective growth agonist for other
tissues and i ask because you see for
instance in some cases bodybuilders who
have used super physiological doses of
growth hormone for a long period of time
and they look like they're six to nine
months pregnant yeah at rest i mean
because their viscera have grown yeah
any thoughts
i'm not sure exactly what you're asking
about rapamycin is there a risk that it
grows
a wide spectrum of tissue it's
interesting so people who know about
rapamycin and mtor a lot actually have
the reverse concern so it turns out mtor
again the the protein that rapamycin
inhibits promotes growth and so
bodybuilders often will try to hyper
activate mtor you'll see these in fact
it's funny because some of the
bodybuilder mixes of like leucine and
other amino acids is like you know mtor
activator on the bottle right so they
actually try to activate mtor so most
people would think if you inhibit mtor
you're actually going to reduce growth
and actually potentially lead to
something like sarcopenia it turns out
that's not the case that's another
tissue where it's sort of amazing
sarcopenia always age-related muscle
loss or just muscle that's a good
question i i'm not i'm not a muscle
person either i don't know what i do but
i know what i don't do
so
i think of it
you're a muscle person yeah yeah very
effective
but mostly i think about it in the
context of aging yeah related muscle
loss so i don't know of any reason to be
worried that rapamycin would cause over
proliferation of bone or other types of
tissue but you know this is pretty new
right and i think before we did these
experiments most people would have
thought if anything we would expect to
see a loss of bone
but in reality what we saw was the
reverse and i think this may come back
to this inflammatory state so this is
the thing right when you have a chronic
inflammatory state in your tissues that
actually impairs the ability of stem
cells to do what they normally would do
and i also think that's probably the
biggest reason why rapamycin can improve
function in some tissues with age
because what you're really doing is
you're knocking down that chronic
inflammatory state and then the stem
cells are like oh wow more resources go
back and do my job yeah so i think that
might be what what's happening and we
have some molecular understanding of
what's going on in the bone but yeah i
do think the point you raised is a good
one that we do want to watch out with
not just rapamycin but any intervention
we're using to target the biology of
aging we do want to watch out for the
possibility that we might take these
systems that are functioning at a
sub-optimal level and instead of
bringing them back to optimal we bring
it too far so i think that's always a
something we want to pay attention to
the other place that this hasn't really
gotten into the public awareness yet but
i was just at perfect the reproductive
aging conference a couple of weeks ago
this is a new area of aging biology
that's super fascinating and it's mostly
focused on female reproductive aging
i saw probably three different talks on
rapamycin rejuvenating ovarian function
yeah really really fascinating is
interesting and my good friend you shin
soo and zev williams at columbia are
actually
starting a clinical trial
of rapamycin in
women who are undergoing premature
ovarian failure so i think we may get
some data on this you know in the not
too distant future in people and in
parallel john john on the former
graduate student of mine i mentioned
he's now an assistant professor at the
university of washington is starting a
clinical trial for periodontal disease
with rapamycin so i'm pretty excited to
see where this goes and and hopefully
we'll get some data in people in the
near future
why cycle off of rapamycin aside from is
there are there reasons aside from the
experimental designs that have been
published right because i can understand
why yeah why we'll just keep taking it
why not keep taking yeah and lots of
people have done that in mice so in mice
people have given rapamycin from a very
young age all the way through to old age
and death some people have started in
middle age and then some people have
done these transient treatments that i
mentioned so in mice
you get most of the benefit in terms of
lifespan at least from starting in
middle age and going to the end of life
and even the experiment we did was a
12-week transient treatment looks like
you get most of the benefits for
lifespan maybe not quite as big but you
get most of the benefits from just a
single 12-week treatment now mice
obviously age a lot faster than people i
don't have no idea that that would have
anything to do with 12 weeks and people
but but that's the observation so then
the question is why wouldn't you want to
do a continuous treatment so most
physicians who
know about rapamycin first of all it's
usually called serolimus in the clinical
world so it's the same drug but two
different names how do you spell that
i've never read that i-r-o-l-i-m-u-s
serolimus is how i say it cyrolimus is
how people who know what they're talking
about say it if you're a physician
that's the name you would know it under
or rap immune which is the generic
sounds like the name of a scribe from
lord of the rings anyway it continues
yeah so most physicians if they know
anything about rapid rapamycin or now
i'm going to say rapalimus
rapamycin or ceralymus they are going to
know about it in the context of organ
transplant patients so in organ
transplant patients they've been taking
high doses of the drugs usually with
strong immune suppressants
and in that context there are side
effects associated with rapamycin so the
concern of course the reason why you
might not want to take rapamycin
continuously is that maybe the risk of
side effects goes up the longer you take
it
so that would be one rationale for not
taking it continuously and that's more
or less my rationale i know lots of
people who take rapamycin continuously
and and have not experienced side
effects but that's sort of my reasoning
the first thing is i'm very much a
realist about this i recognize this is
self-experimentation we don't have
clinical trials we don't know
with any
real quantitative estimate of risk
reward i know enough that i believe that
the risk reward ratio is strongly
favoring reward especially when i was
experiencing frozen shoulder but even
still you know i take rapamycin off and
on but we don't really know and so my
view was in the animals and especially
going back to this chronic inflammation
model the idea that periodically
knocking down that chronic inflammation
and then it'll take a while for it to
come back makes sense
and so that's really the rationale that
i started with because i recognize that
this is unknown territory that it is
experimentation
i don't have a great
reason to think that continuous would be
better than
repeated cycles dose is still a little
bit of a guess so i don't worry too much
about being very precise and all of that
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
ag-1 by athletic greens if you're
traveling if you're just busy you're not
sure if your meals or where they should
be it covers your bases with
approximately 75 vitamins minerals and
whole foods sourced ingredients you'll
be hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense formula on the market it
has a multivitamin multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes and adaptogens you get
the idea right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
let me
revert back to the dog aging project for
a second you mentioned the clinical
study side
and i would love for you to describe the
hypothesis going into that what what is
the and i has did use the word hope
right but
with the intervention of rapamycin
what might you see based on
previous
data or
studies
so let me take a step back because i
think it's useful to first just briefly
talk about how this idea even came about
because really in my mind i think the
first time i really
thought of the idea of doing a clinical
trial in dogs was i was going on 10
years ago now i think it was probably
2013. and daniel promisello is
co-director of the dog aging project and
kate creevy who's our chief veterinary
officer had been thinking about the
longitudinal study well before this so i
actually was actually in conversations
with them that got me thinking about
companion dogs living in the human
environment as a an animal that we could
actually study and learn about the
biology of aging and i'm a dog person
i've always had dogs and so the idea
when it solidified in my mind there's
really no reason why
these interventions that we can increase
lifespan and healthspan and mice they're
going to work in dogs like i am i don't
know that all of them are going to work
i don't know rapamycin is going to work
but i am 100 rock solid confident that
some of them are going to work and being
a dog guy and wanting my dog to live
longer
when that light bulb went off in my head
i was like
this goddamn has to happen yeah right
this has to happen and so that was
really what got me on the path of then
thinking okay how do we do it how do we
actually
how do we start that process how do we
actually test whether or not an
intervention i hadn't settled on
rapamycin at that time
would have this effect in dogs and so
that was the process of going through
how do you set up a clinical trial one
thing to consider is companion dogs very
much like people's children so you kind
of think about a clinical trial the way
you would a pediatric clinical trial you
really have to be sure
whatever intervention you're using isn't
going to kill somebody's dog or harm
somebody's dog so these are all the
things that i started thinking about and
i settled on rapamycin because
there was enough evidence at that point
to convince me that it could be done
safely that was really the only concern
with rapamycin based on the side effects
i talked about in organ transplant
patients that it could be done safely
and because it was our best bet for the
interventions that we knew about then
and i would say still now
for being likely to have an effect on
lifespan and health span for the reasons
that we've sort of already gotten into
so what might we expect based on
what we know in
mice
so i talked about some of the tissues
where rapamycin makes things better
there are many other tissues where it
hasn't really been looked at in that
context of better but where at least if
you give it lifelong
the declines are delayed at a minimum we
can say that so that's true in brain
it's true in kidney it's true in liver
may i pause for a second what type of
degeneration or changes are delayed or
reversed in the brain
this has been studied both in the
context of normal aging and in mouse
models of alzheimer's disease and other
neurodegenerative diseases in every case
you see improvements in function so
these are behavioral tests and mice
there are these water maze tests things
like that right so to the extent
that they are actually telling us what
we think they're telling us about
cognition you see improvements in the
rapamycin treated mice versus the
controls performance
task performance definitely those
functional measures are the ones that i
put the most faith in right i think sure
you want to see changes in pathology and
molecular biomarkers and things like
that i don't care if the biomarker
changes if it doesn't make it function
better though so that's why i start
there but people have done lots of
studies looking at cerebral blood flow
so that's one model that's been put
forth there's decreases in
neuroinflammation as we would expect
given the effect of rapamycin
inflammation and increases in metabolic
function or mitochondrial function in
the brain so there are plausible
molecular mechanisms by which rapamycin
could be having these effects and that's
pretty much
true in the other tissues where
rapamycin has been shown to have effects
is a lot of people have been studying
this and made i think reasonable models
at a molecular level for how rapamycin
is acting so i'll just i'll cut it short
and just say pretty much every tissue
where people have looked you can find
evidence that function has been at least
preserved the one that might be worth
commenting on briefly and coming back to
because we touched on it is muscle so
early on there was a lot of concern i
think particularly among muscle
biologists that rapamycin would increase
sarcopenia or or enhance muscle loss
with aging and make things worse and
that's because it's known in muscle
biology that mtor
promotes muscle growth or at least it's
required for protein synthesis which is
part of muscle growth so the
conventional wisdom was that when you
inhibit mtor that would lead to a
decrease in muscle mass muscle function
several studies now in both mice and
rats have shown it's exactly the
opposite you maintain muscle function
better with age
when the mice or the rats are given
rapamycin now dose is probably important
so i do think if you were to push the
dose too far you know you might impair
muscle growth or muscle maintenance but
if the doses that also extend lifespan
and have all these other effects
muscle is actually functioning better in
old animals than in control animals and
this is why i constantly i constantly
tell the people in my lab and other
scientists you've got to do the
experiment you cannot go into it
thinking that you know the answer and
not do the experiment because your
dogmatic belief says this is how it's
going to work you got to do the
experiment
so based on the
mice data let's just say
lifespan in terms of percentage
increase in this case what might be the
the range i think the upper side for
what's been shown in mice so far with
rapamycin is about 25 increase in in
lifespan i do and i mean that's
certainly possible in dogs i i would say
if i had to guess i would guess it's not
going to be that the magnitude of effect
on a percent basis is not going to be as
big in longer-lived animals that's just
a guess i don't have any data to support
that which you know might mean that the
the the magnitude of effect in people is
is going to be even smaller because
people are much longer lived than than
dogs are and much longer lived than
misar so but it could be as much as 25
so you know if you're talking about a
large dog that maybe would normally live
to be 14 years old you're talking
another three years study worth doing
and i say that as i'm looking around you
to
my dog molly seven years of age laying
on the floor
and
the function matters right i mean the
function really matters absolutely i
think most people would agree that the
function matters more than the absolute
lifespan i think almost everybody
says if you ask them you know would you
want to live longer
they're like no not if i'm going to live
longer in a decrepit state
now is it fair to say that that is one
of the valid criticisms of at least
certain forms of say caloric restriction
well i don't know maybe i mean i
wouldn't necessarily pick on caloric
restriction i think there's evidence
that at least in mice that caloric
restriction can maintain function later
in life as well now you could make an
argument about quality of life for sure
i would pick on caloric restriction then
in people but i think the general
question is that a valid concern in
targeting the biology of aging i would
say it is and it isn't so
nothing that i have ever seen
and i've seen a lot of things that
extend lifespan
nothing has ever
convincingly extended the
bad part of life the decrepit state
there's a little bit of debate in the c
elegans field about that but i think
that's these are people arguing over
silly stuff i've never seen anything
that does that it's c elegance
it's a nematode worm it is right
nematode yeah even there i think it's a
it's a semantic argument not a real
argument but certainly in mammals
nothing that extends lifespan
makes the end period only extends the
end period of life i think it's a
legitimate question whether some of
these interventions might
proportionately extend lifespan where
you're proportionately extending
healthspan but you also at an absolute
sense do have a longer period of decline
that is hard to really completely
resolve i would say things like
rapamycin and caloric restriction which
those are the two most potent
interventions we've got right now really
do seem in mice to push the declines in
function and diseases back later into
life so you really have
disproportionately extended health span
compared to lifespan
but again that's my interpretation of
the data but it's a hard case to make
quantitatively
when you were
considering different candidates as
interventions
for this dog aging project rapamycin
that ended up being
the top pick
what would have been the second and
third place
finishers so to speak the first thing
i'd say is i think if i had like a
boatload of money and and i could test
10 interventions i would not
try to make the decision myself so i'll
give you my list i'm not dodging the
question but i would get a bunch of my
best friends who i also respect their
science together and and sit down and
talk about it because i certainly
think that we could come to a better
collective decision but i think the
place where i would start are with
interventions that
robustly and reproducibly extend
lifespan in mice i think you'd have to
take a look at caloric restriction i
think there would be some concerns about
caloric restriction in companion dogs
and you know also the logistics of wood
owners actually
do that so i probably wouldn't include
caloric restriction but you would think
about other forms of caloric restriction
and maybe that's a topic we want to talk
about as well like pharmacological
interventions that cause things like
that intermittent fasting you know time
restricted feeding things like that so
other nutritional interventions that
maybe aren't as severe or maybe not as
hard for owners to adhere to yeah but
then there are a series of small
molecules that have come out of
something called the interventions
testing program so this is a
national institute on aging funded
program to do what the name says test
interventions in mice for the ability to
extend lifespan and this is kind of the
gold standard so there are lots of labs
including mine that are out there that
do lifespan experiments but this is kind
of the gold standard because it's got
built-in triplicate replication so the
studies all get done at three different
sites and they have
shown a handful of small molecules that
extend lifespan in mice interestingly
and this is something people don't
really understand many of them only
extend lifespan in one sex or the other
in mice yeah and it tends to favor males
so more drugs extend lifespan in males
than in females so maybe we'll break
even with the
average life we can catch up to the to
the females yeah so nobody understands
that that's another area that people are
really interested in so rapamycin has
been shown repeatedly by the
interventions testing program to extend
lifespan in both males and females and
it's the biggest effect but there are
other drugs like acarbose which is an
anti-diabetic drug
that is in males at least close to
rapamycin in terms of the magnitude of
effect 17 alpha estradiol which is a sex
hormone extends lifespan in males ndga
is another one so there are probably six
or seven
small molecules that have come out of
that program that would make sense to
think about testing in dogs again
because like i said this is almost like
doing a pediatric clinical trial first
thing is what do we know about this
molecule in dogs can it be done safely
and then there are a couple of others
that i would put on the short list
not because they've extended lifespan by
the itp but because there's so much buzz
around them in the field and because
there is some evidence that they can
extend health span and two that i think
would fit in that category are metformin
which is the most commonly prescribed
anti-diabetic drug in the world
probably most people listening to your
podcast have heard of metformin it's
gotten a lot of attention
for its potential effects on longevity
and near barzillai einstein has been
championing a human clinical trial
called tame which stands for targeting
aging with metformin and if you want to
talk about that i'm happy to but i think
because we know a lot about metformin
and its effects on
metabolic health and it's been
talked about so much in the field that
probably makes sense to look at nad
precursors is the other class of
molecules i would put in that bucket
actually and a nicotinamide riboside
which is an nad precursor did not extend
lifespan by the itp
but there's a lot of evidence that you
can have beneficial effects on metabolic
health and health in general and nad
precursors are almost certain to be safe
so again coming back to the you know
doing this in dogs and then there's a
couple of others that i am interested in
that are more recent one is alpha
ketoglutarate which is a natural product
metabolite that a lot of people are
thinking about now there's one study
that showed a small life span extension
in mice and the other is a molecule
there's two that actually are thought to
target autophagy or mitophagy
mitochondrial autophagy one is called
spermadine and the other is called
urolithin a and so i would take a close
look at those but you know again that's
a short list and we could you know
if i sat down with my friends for an
hour we could probably come up with an
an equal number of other things to to
kind of think about okay
let me you asked oh of course i did
that's my job so i want to take a closer
look at a few of these especially a
number that i don't recognize
actually before we do that
i know you talk to your smart friends
but since they are your close friends
presumably you've probably spoken about
this before so let's just say
you were benevolent dictator
of
the
targeting aging clinical trials program
and you had to pick one of these aside
from rapamycin
not holding you to it clearly this is
just a thought exercise but where would
you lean
and actually you know what i'm gonna
take metformin off the list just to make
it easier okay i wouldn't have gone with
metformin anyways
i would
probably go with alpha ketoglutarate but
i would
take a close look at urolithin a and
spermidine can you tell me more about
uralythin a and spermidine yeah and what
those are used for currently so
spermadine is found in in food right so
we get spermatine in our diet but it's
usually at a pretty low level so
spermadine again there are several labs
that have worked on this unfortunately i
can't remember the the japanese
scientists we'll find a few and we can
put it in the chat who has shown
correlations between dietary consumption
of spermadine and
mortality and other health outcomes in
people
and then frank madeo was the first to
really start studying this in the basic
biology of aging site and has shown that
you can extend lifespan in a few
different organisms i can't remember if
there's a really strong lifespan i think
there's a lifespan study in mice that
looks pretty good but certainly a bunch
of health span measures in mice that are
treated with spermidine and the
mechanism is through they think through
enhancing autophagy which is this mtor
regulated process so rapamycin also
turns up autophagy
and you know some people will kind of
refer to it as the recycling center of
the cell and one way to think about it
is we know that as we age there's an
accumulation of a bunch of damaged stuff
and autophagy is a mechanism to help
clear that damage and then recycle the
components so they can be used to build
new functional machines so spermadine is
an autophagy booster and there are a
bunch of companies actually trying to
make pharmacological autophagy boosters
so that's the mechanism for spermadine
and then eurolython a is also an
autophagy booster i don't know as much
about the
source of urolithine it is a natural
product but i don't know as much about
the source but it seems to
preferentially boost a specific type of
autophagy called mitophagy or
mitochondrial autophagy and so the idea
is there that you're you're kind of
restoring
metabolic function by
breaking down the damaged mitochondria
and making new mitochondria and that has
been shown to extend lifespan in it
started in worms and i think there's a
mouse study but there's also now been
at least one clinical trial which i this
is new i haven't really had a chance to
dive into the clinical trial in depth
i'm kind of waiting for peter attia to
do that for me
tell me what's wrong with it no i'm just
kidding but my quick glance at the trial
it looked pretty interesting it looked
like there may have been some
improvements in muscle function in older
people taking urolithin a which is what
we would expect if you're really
enhancing mitophagy that study was of
course funded by the company that's
trying to develop this and sell it so
you know there are some conflicts of
interest there but i think companies can
fund and do good clinical trials i just
haven't had a chance to dive into it and
really evaluate it
what
is the function
or significance of 17 alpha estradiol i
don't think people really know the
mechanism there at this point there are
a lot of things that have been proposed
and i think that's really a mystery
right now how it's working to extend is
it working
selectively in males yes
okay
yeah yeah yeah that's one of the ones
where it's only in only in males
and whether it's having feminizing
effects i don't know that people have
really looked closely at that or a
cardio protective effect yeah although
in mice most people would say that a
significant fraction of mice die from
cancer depending on the strain
background it's probably between like 60
and 90 percent that's cancer diet cancer
so and most people would say that
vascular disease at least is not a
significant component of death in mice
maybe
maybe true cardiac disease in a small
fraction interestingly the same thing's
true in dogs about well really about all
certainly vascular disease not a big
cause of death cancer a much greater
cause of death although
i have to be precise
euthanasia is the leading cause of death
in dogs but usually people will
euthanize their dogs for a reason and
cancer is one of the big killers in that
sense so i don't think most people would
immediately think that an intervention
that
prevents vascular disease or even heart
disease would have a big effect on mouse
lifespan if it wasn't also
impacting cancer and potentially also
other age-related diseases that makes
sense so i'd love to visit two more
and
i'll actually
mention the one we'll do second which is
the nad
precursors and i want to ask about this
specifically because it has become very
popular
rightly or wrongly or both who knows
which reasons are being used to justify
it
for people to use intravenous pushes of
nad and various settings it's extremely
popular in austin so i'd like to talk
about that but first
there's one that i have here in my notes
that i'd love to know if you have any
opinion on and i haven't seen this name
in ages i do have some familiarity with
it which is depranil so i haven't seen
this since i was an undergrad at
princeton freshman year reading volume
one of a
series well later became a series called
smart drugs yeah and it talked about
off-label use of all sorts of things
hydrogen
being another example parastam anarastem
long list of stuff but depranil
was in that list and it talked about not
just cognitive benefits but also effects
on libido and so on
do you have any opinion or thoughts on
depernal
that's a really interesting one and in
the context of aging it's sort of a
mystery to me
why this hasn't been studied more so
there are a few old studies of depranil
on lifespan in rodents and actually i
think one or two studies in dogs
that show pretty big effects and then
it's like the literature just stops
and i don't know why
so this is one that based on that
literature i think it's worth looking at
i guess i didn't mention it because it
sort of slipped my mind but yeah there's
as you might imagine there are very few
things that have been reported to extend
lifespan in dogs and this is one of two
that i know of caloric restriction being
the other one and that was in laboratory
dogs so yeah it's fascinating and like i
said i don't know why
that was never carried forward or if
anybody's still thinking about this too
hard to slap a molecular modification on
in patent i mean who knows well yeah i
mean that's a whole right that's a whole
other challenge for sure rapamycin is
kind of in that boat too because it's
off patent yeah maybe it had to do with
the lack of
profit motive but i i really don't know
actually unless except for the people
who were studying it were never
in the mainstream aging biology
community and i think like you know many
other fields when work gets done outside
of that
to the extent that aging biology is
mainstream it never used to be but
outside of that mainstream it kind of
people don't know about it right or they
just ignore it
all right i'm going to put a bookmark to
revisit
deprinell after this conversation and if
people have some idea of why the
research stalled in the way that it
appears to have stalled
let us know on twitter i would be very
very interested
nad precursors now
nad nad plus
is there any difference between those
two are those identical most people just
yeah if you don't put the plus on there
everybody will know what you're talking
about it's just so so there's nad
plus and nadh and that's just the
oxidized and reduced forms of nad i see
and this is a nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide is what that stands for and
this is a cofactor in a whole bunch of
different metabolic reactions probably
thousands and so it has a really
important role in
central metabolism but also a lot of
other cellular functions and
you know what has sort of emerged is
i don't know if i would say a consensus
certainly a lot of papers published that
nad levels decline with age and the idea
that if you can boost nad levels that
that would have a beneficial effect on
metabolism now i am
massively oversimplifying and there are
some very specific models which gained a
lot of attention related to how that's
working but i think from a general
perspective it probably is the case
certainly in some tissues nad levels
decline with age the reasons for that
are not completely
known
and there's some reason to believe that
if you can successfully reverse that
that there are some metabolic benefits
to doing so and that's the general idea
behind
intravenous nad or nad precursors which
are
small molecules that you don't have to
take intravenously so nad is not taken
up there's no bioavailability if you
just eat it so these nad precursors are
small molecules that
in theory again there's some controversy
around this but in theory have
bioavailability and can be taken up to
boost nad and cells yeah i'm not going
to name names i was talking to someone
who's very skeptical of some of the
dietary supplement companies that have
been built around nad
precursors including open questions
around whether or not
they remain viable
if they are not refrigerated so if
they're on a shelf for two or three
weeks
lots of open questions what do you do
aside from
intermittent use of rapamycin
for yourself in terms of
improving health span
potentially improving lifespan what are
what are other
levers that you're pulling well i can't
tell you
no i mean i mean the honest answer is
rapamycin is about as edgy as i get and
that's actually pretty edgy for a lot of
people but um you know the other stuff
that i do is what what i try to do is as
i think what we all more or less
know we should try to do i really don't
take any supplements i am pretty averse
to supplements that might be something
that's worth touching on again you kind
of alluded to this a minute ago but i
don't take any supplements i do
periodically take vitamin d when i
remember to that's mostly because my
wife tells me i should but really what i
try to do is i i've found for me
personally and i'm very much of the
belief that nutrition and diet is very
individual for example my wife and i are
completely different in the way we
respond to carbs and i found that what
works really well for me
is a
low simple carbohydrate diet i've tried
keto just to try it but i don't do a
ketogenic diet but i do stay away
typically from bread and rice and you
know certainly things that have a lot of
sugar added to them and that works
really well for me but i'll also say i
don't get cravings for that stuff so
it's easy it's been easy for me to adopt
that lifestyle so i think that's been
really important for me and it's been
several years now that i've been doing
that and that's helped a lot and if i
had to pick one thing though it would be
resistance exercise that is the one
thing that
i think almost everybody should do to
give themselves the best opportunity to
be healthy as long as possible other
forms of exercise i'm not against cardio
all that stuff but i think if i had to
pick one
maintaining your muscle mass and getting
as much muscle as you can especially in
your 40s and 50s is really important
later on so i try to exercise and i
enjoy exercising so it isn't a huge
burden for me and then sleep is the big
one right and i and that that's harder
to control if you have trouble sleeping
you can develop strategies to help with
that but it's not like diet and exercise
where you really have complete control
if you really want to over that but
that's a big one and i'm again have been
really fortunate that i tend not to have
problems falling asleep and usually
staying asleep so
what i would trade
i know and again my wife is in the camp
where she struggled with that a little
bit and there are lots of strategies
that people can can develop has she
found anything to help
i don't want to speak for her but i mean
i would say i think partly exercise so
being physically active she gets out and
hikes a lot and that helps not
napping during the day is is also a big
one i would say
let's come back to
our list of acronyms and
i also would like to speak about
caloric restriction a bit okay so
i'll just pose a simple question
should
molly be doing intermittent fasting as a
stratagem for
increasing
lifespan so i'm not a veterinarian i do
not give veterinary advice right yes we
should say and i'll add another
disclaimer to the top of this show none
of us is not a doctor
we are not giving medical advice i'm not
that kind of doctor yeah this is for
informational purposes only so consider
your health professional for any
decision i mean i do think that's
important so i'll answer i'll answer
your question in a second but i mean i
do always try to make this point because
like as you might imagine i get asked
all the time about rapamycin for
themselves for their dogs other things
they should be taking and almost all of
this right with the exception of diet
and exercise and and the other thing not
smoking things like that almost all of
this is unknown territory right and so i
for myself do not feel that i should be
telling other people what they should do
i'm happy to share what i do and what i
think works for me but i
none of this stuff has gone through
clinical trials we have nothing that has
been formally shown to impact the
biological aging process in a positive
way increase lifespan and health span
beyond like i said diet and exercise you
mean in humans in humans yeah sorry yeah
or even in dogs right that's we're doing
the first clinical trial for healthy
aging in dogs so i think people just
have to recognize we don't have that
level of proof and it's going to be a
long time and i shouldn't even say proof
because there are things that go through
clinical trials and then we find out
later on that they aren't having the
benefits people thought so i think we
always have to recognize there's a level
of uncertainty and
risk reward evaluation that has to come
into that okay i'll get down off my
soapbox so should you consider
time-restricted feeding for your dog so
the first thing i would say is and this
really i think you know the reason why
why i even thought about this was
because
in
the mouse studies and and this has been
sort of popularized into the the
mainstream culture and people as well
there are all these say calorie
restriction alternative diets that
people have started thinking about like
intermittent fasting time restricted
feeding ketogenic diet fasting mimicking
diet and so
that gets presented to the general
public as if these things have all been
proven to work and that's i'm just going
to say it that's [ __ ] when you
actually look at the mouse data there is
very little evidence if you don't
calorically restrict that these things
have any significant impact on lifespan
maybe some health spend metrics but they
get presented as if they do so if you do
those things and calorically restrict
yes they will increase life spending
money but if you limit your window and
eat twice the number of calories
very very in fact if anything or just
isochloric yeah that's right that's
right there's very little evidence that
they have significant benefits okay and
in some cases it might actually make
things worse so i but and so i
recognized that and we actually wrote a
review i'm going on a year ago now on
this topic and so i thought our dogs in
the dog study the longitudinal study of
the dog aging project might be a really
interesting
natural model to look at this because
some owners feed their dogs once a day
some twice a day some three times a day
some do what we call ad libitum or
free-feeding right the dog always has
access to food so like google engineers
when they have a snack bar right around
the corner this is actually a really
fascinating question that i'm interested
in which is certainly there's a
self-selection to free feeding in dogs
right if you have one of those dogs that
will just eat until it
gets sick you're not going to free feed
your dog there's some probably genetic
component that some dogs can be have
access to food all the time and they
just won't overeat that's really
fascinating biology there and i don't
really think people understand it yet
but that's a different question so but
this occurred to me that we had an
opportunity to actually look at this in
our study and so what we did was we just
looked at the survey data from the 40 at
that time i guess they're about 25 000
dogs in what we call the pack that's the
the largest part of the longitudinal
study and we just asked a very very
conceptually simple question if we bin
the dogs by fed once a day versus fed
more than once a day are there
differences in disease diagnoses now
this is all owner reported but in our
primary survey instrument the owners are
asked to list all the diseases that
their dog has been diagnosed with so
it's pretty good maybe not quite as good
as a veterinary record but pretty good
and we looked at i think 10 different
age-related categories
and i didn't think this was going to
work like i thought because i don't i
still don't believe in time restricted
feeding despite the data no that's
that's not true i thought there was no
way we were going to see anything here
but it was striking in six of the ten
the dogs that were fed once a day
had lower risk than the dogs that were
fed
more than once again just just so i
understand when you say six out of ten
yeah so think things like cognitive
function kidney disease
so disease categories
categories they were all going the right
direction and six of them it was
statistically significant which in my
experience is a really really strong
result were the other four no
discernible effect or did they move in
the opposite direction no they were all
going the right direction they didn't
just didn't all reach statistically
significant so then the question is is
this causal i don't know so again these
are this is an observational study it's
also what's called cross-sectional so we
only have one time point for each dog
correlation does not equal causation and
you could think of plausible
explanations here right so a dog fed
once a day
i'm guessing is less likely to be obese
maybe that's why the dogs fed once a day
are
at lower risk for a bunch of diagnoses
right that seems pretty reasonable to me
so i don't know that that time
restricted feeding is causal for
this outcome the other question is of
course owners are thinking should i
change i want my dog to be healthy or
should i feed my dog once a day my
gut feeling here is that if your dog has
been on say a twice a day feeding diet
for
several years i wouldn't change like we
didn't change the diet for our dog
i would not try to take a dog that's
used to eating two or three times a day
and be like sorry you're getting one
meal a day from here on out i think what
needs to happen now is an actual
directed study to try to understand the
first question which is
is it the case the dog's fed once a day
directly experimental yeah right so
instead of being just observational do
some sort of mechanistic maybe clinical
trial kind of study
we can through observation in principle
answer the question are dogs fed once a
day less likely to be obese because we
could just go back to the owners and ask
that but then we really need to do
studies to understand it is there real
mechanism here connecting once a day
feeding to health outcomes and even if
it's just in about obesity once a day
feeding might be a pretty good strategy
to combat obesity at least in dogs
humans the problem with humans of course
you know but where do we begin well yeah
humans are funny animals that's for sure
with dogs you can control when they're
fed as an owner right now that depends a
little bit on your
ability to control yourself from giving
you're saying i need a bigger cage for
my kids
but but in humans that's hard and here's
the other issue i have with the whole
dietary restriction nutritional aging
nutritional longevity stuff is
people pay no attention to the
psychological consequences that go along
with
trying to practice caloric restriction
or trying to practice time restricted
feeding or intermittent fasting i'm not
saying they're bad for everybody but i
know a lot of people who've dabbled with
these things and and i would say some of
the psychological effects aren't great
but i think that comes down to the whole
way that diet is integrated with our
culture and our social interactions and
it's hard to be hungry when you've got
high calorie delicious tasting food and
on every corner right so i think it
really
it does have an effect that we don't
understand and don't pay much attention
to
let's zoom out a little bit and just
survey the landscape of scientific
research as it relates to
i'll just use the term longevity for
simplicity
what are the constraints right now
if any holding this field back is it as
simple as funding you know if elon musk
decided you know what
this seems like a good place to
park some capital and put it to work i'm
going to dedicate
10 billion a billion a year over the
next 10 years yeah does that
on some level solve the problem or are
there other constraints preventing
research from being done that would be
let's just say
maximally valuable in the next five to
ten years great question and we might
get the answer to that so i don't know
if you've heard of this evolution
foundation and i have not evolution it's
like evolution with an h
this is a foundation that is funded by
the saudi government and some people
have a lot of concerns about that i
personally have some concerns about that
but that aside why is it called
evolution health evolution i think so
yeah okay um and a lot of the female
scientists i know really don't like oh
he yeah
yeah just saying guys i can see if you
might if you can change that name you
might think about another problem that
china doesn't have
it's all the same anyway so so in any
case they have said and announced that
they will be putting
about a billion dollars a year
into this area
going forward i'm embarrassed this is a
royal decree this is there's like i
don't know for sure this is what i've
heard there have been two royal decrees
in the last century and this is one of
them so
so we might find out so we'll see so
first of all i would say it's going to
take some time if we just put the
relative level of funding and we compare
it to something like
cancer research so cancer research right
now gets just from nih about six billion
dollars a year and that's not dod and
other sources of funding biology of
aging gets about 350 million so it's
been minuscule compared to just cancer
where are all the billionaires who are
terrified of dying
because i know they're when i meet these
tech magnates well
they're very they're very eager to live
to 120 but they don't seem to be i mean
i think first of all we want to be
realistic in what we promise people
right but uh or at least i do some other
people don't i'm not doing anything i'm
not trying to say anything about what
you promised it's just what they want
yeah right yeah yeah i mean certainly
there have been lots of stories written
about high net worth individuals funding
research in this area but what i would
say is it's only been really i would say
within the last two decades that the
research in the field has matured to the
point where
it legitimately
should be getting
the level of funding that cancer's been
getting for the last 50 years right
since the war on cancer was declared and
i you know i got myself in a little bit
of a little bit of heat on twitter for
saying this but i'll say it again
because i believe it right it's funny
because you get people working in the
cancer field poking fun at the longevity
field or aging research field whatever
you want to call it and i'm like look
when the war on cancer was declared 50
years ago cancer was the second leading
cause of death in the united states
behind heart disease guess where it is
today
number two
[Laughter]
so i would not throw rocks at uh when
you've been getting six billion dollars
a year at least for the last 50 years
and i would also say
and i think we'll find out if that level
of resources was put towards targeting
the biology of aging the payoff is much
much greater i mean we can look at this
in a lot of different ways but but one
easy way to look at it because the math
is pretty easy is what is the impact on
life expectancy
from curing cancer
for a typical 50 year old woman have you
seen this before what's your guess if i
had a pill and i said this pill will
cure all forms of cancer
what's your guess for life expectancy
okay so this is we have we have a
a healthy 50 year old don't don't
overthink it population level okay when
would you what would we expect what's
the average increase in life expectancy
if we just got rid of cancer took it out
of the equation for all human beings
five years it's pretty close three years
yeah same thing for heart disease if you
do both you get about seven years
so why is that it's because you didn't
do anything about kidney disease and
alzheimer's disease and you know all the
other
declines and functioning diseases that
go along with aging so if you take a
different approach and you try to target
the root biology that is leading to
at least a permissive state for all of
these diseases the potential to increase
lifespan is much greater
but really the potential to maximize
health span is is even
bigger right because if you only fix one
disease you're not fixing all the other
declines whereas potentially you could
fix many maybe all of these things at
the same time so we'll find out but i
think the promise is much much greater
than it's ever been from this disease
first approach okay so
again
asking as a as an amateur
in the get a literal etymological sense
of the word i love this stuff
and i'm involved on some level as a
funder with early stage science what i
have seen is not all
let's call it sectors or area of
research are in a position to
make use of large amounts of capital
yeah so and it's a bit of a chicken and
the egg problem perhaps but
are there other things that would need
to happen for let's say someone's
listening and they say great this is
what i've been looking for i want to put
a hundred million dollars to work
because i have so much money that i make
that up every two years anyway or every
year
is there a way for them to even do that
meaningfully at this point right i think
it's a really important question and
again i think we'll find out so i think
the field as a whole if this billion
dollars a year actually materializes one
question is will it be
deployed in a
efficient and useful way that
we'll see
but related to that is can it be
deployed in an efficient and useful way
in other words are there projects where
you could spend that much money i think
it will be hard but it's
doable if
researchers from outside the field are
brought in because right now it's a
fairly small pool of people who've been
trained in the field and i know that's
part of the goal with evolution is to
entice other people to come into the
field the place where if it was me
i'm sorry to laugh
the more i think about it the more i'm
like wow that is an a very fascinating
branding decision like
i could have had a second meeting on
that one but yes please continue now the
billion just also so i have a clear
understanding is that billion in part
allocated to for-profit ventures yes
yeah it's interesting so this is my
understanding and they may change it but
my understanding is roughly two-thirds
will go to non-profit as grants they
call them donations for some reason but
same things what we know of as grants
and about one-third will go into
investment so that that's the way i
understand it right yeah i think that's
good i mean i think it's good that
they're they're thinking about both the
the private sector and public sector for
sure
is the
what was the term you used for the area
aging research is that the way to put it
i suppose i call it all sorts of stuff
but yeah so if i think about my
experience in
science related to psychedelic compounds
broadly speaking when we start to get
into therapeutics as i understand it the
fda is very interested in the ability to
scale and deploy a given therapy for
significant number of patients in the
population so in other words if the
infrastructure or other
doesn't exist for instance the number of
therapists required to administer
compounds that
entail a session that is 4 to 12 hours
in length there are a number of issues
that need to be addressed before the fda
will say reschedule something or
allow it to be prescribable
has any of that cropped up with
the aging research and compounds that
are being
examined or because they are already in
circulation like rapamycin
that just doesn't really exist as a
problem so i haven't heard that specific
problem let me come back to fda because
i think this is a really this is there's
a lot of people in the field that have
been thinking about this and there's a
lot of confusion around how you would
actually get in what we would call a
gero science intervention i haven't
introduced that term yet but geroscience
is the area of research that ties
together the biology of aging with
age-related diseases and when you're
thinking about moving a drug into the
clinic
you have to have an end point a disease
or an indication that's what fda
approves a drug based on and general
science is really the connector there so
there are lots of people thinking about
that i want to come back because you
asked me what would i do if somebody
gave me a billion dollars yes and i want
to answer that question because people
there are people
there are people listening who actually
do have the capacity i do think there
are a couple of big areas uh you don't
give me a billion dollars but where i
would like you could if you wanted to
though um
here's my here
um
we'll put the wire that why are why our
instructions up with the show
have any of your guests ever done
anyways i think there are a couple areas
where the field could benefit from a
large infusion of money one is actually
in marketing and what i mean by that is
i think that
we as a field have never been very good
at communicating with the general public
and with policy makers around why this
area is important
and we've been
we
broadly speaking have been very bad at
talking about the nonsense right the
hype and the snake oil and all that
stuff so i think a dedicated
marketing plan with professionals for
how do we communicate
the importance of this research and this
biology to the general public and to
policy makers that's not going to cost
hundreds of millions of dollars but i
think if you put a significant amount of
money towards that you could have an
outsized impact the other area where i
put it are clinical trials
clinical trials are expensive
big companies are scared of moving into
the
gyroscience biology of aging space
because they have yet to see a path to
fda approval for a drug to target aging
so if there was a lot of money available
to accelerate that and create that path
then you know big pharmaceutical
companies are followers right they're
going to follow what has worked for
somebody else then they'll come into the
field i think creating that path is
important and that's really
one of the reasons also why i pushed so
hard for the rapamycin clinical trial in
dogs i thought rapamycin was our best
bet
but
there's no guarantees clinical trials
can fail even if your intervention is
great
but i wanted to create a template that
others could follow and i think we've
been successful at that there are now a
couple of companies that are actually
moving forward with developing drugs and
starting to think about doing clinical
trials for aging in companion animals so
i think that same kind of template on
the human side
would be really valuable and so really
i'd love to see
three or four or five big clinical
trials in people
targeting indications relevant for the
biology of aging and i think that you
could spend a billion dollars doing that
give any suggestions for what those
might look like
within a time frame yeah that would be
i'm struggling for the adjective here
practical right because if you don't
know until someone's dead
there are issues with awaiting and not
just awaiting those results but funding
something for absolutely so i mean
that's the beauty of course of doing a
clinical trial in dogs right we all know
dogs age about seven times faster than
people do so you can do a lifespan
clinical trial in a reasonable time
frame if you start with middle-aged dogs
and that's exactly what we're doing you
can't do a lifespan clinical trial in
people because instead of three years
it's going to take you
21 years or whatever you know roughly so
so how what would you look at so there
are a few strategies that people are
taking one is the kind of strategy that
is being taken with the targeting aging
with metformin trial or tame trial that
i mentioned that's what's called a
comorbidity study so it's looking at
frequency of age-related disease
diagnoses and specifically
the length of time that it takes from
when somebody is diagnosed with one
age-related disease before they get the
second age-related disease now the
conceptual advance with tame and i think
why it's potentially powerful is
they have gotten agreement from fda
to consider a collection of age-related
diseases as one
indication one endpoint sort of like a
syndrome x type of situation so what
that then gives you is sure any one
person may have a low percentage chance
of developing alzheimer's disease or
age-related cancer or kidney disease but
if you get
diagnosis for any of those as your
endpoint then you have a much higher
chance and it takes less time to do the
study so that's one approach right it's
still a disease focused approach but
it's a collection of diseases as opposed
to a single outcome
the other approach and i think that this
could absolutely be done is to look at
age-related indications that have a
shorter time frame so functional
measures of aging so you can look at a
variety of functional measures of aging
one example would be immune function
right so there actually was a company
that tried to do this they were called
restore bio they were actually working
with a derivative of rapamycin at first
and they published two clinical trials
where they showed that in
older people of normal health status i'm
intentionally using that kind of ugly
phrase because i don't want to say
healthy older people because i think
people don't understand when they think
healthy they think that it is
like fully functional i'm a healthy 51
year old as we've talked about i am also
a damaged 51 year old so i'm not i'm
healthy i'm abnormal health status but
i'm not fully functional
so anyways an aging survivor that's
right
so so they did this study in in older
people who are you know who are
functioning appropriately for their age
did not have any significant age-related
disease two phase two clinical trials
showed that six weeks with the
derivative of rapamycin boosted
influenza vaccine response
they went to their pivotal they switched
the drug took out the rapamycin
derivative put in a different mtor
inhibitor that works by a different
mechanism
and they weren't hitting their endpoint
this is a little bit of a tangent but
it's a fascinating story they weren't
hitting their end point
which was patient reported infections so
the fda told them that they had to go
with patient reported instead of
laboratory confirmed which is crazy in
any case
it makes no sense but
fda fda felt that patient quality of
life was more important than whether
they were actually self-reporting john
manick has a paper anyways so they
weren't hitting the end point they were
going to do two trials one in the
southern hemisphere in the flu season
and the other in the northern hemisphere
i think they got to the southern
hemisphere
and they got the interim results for the
first half of the trial and they weren't
hitting the patient reported endpoints
and so the board of directors voted to
stop the pivotal clinical trial instead
of spending the money on the second half
november 2019 was when that decision was
oh
and i can't help but think if they knew
where the world was going to be five
months later they might have thought
differently
so it turns out joan has published now
in an after report
that
not every virus but for several viruses
the people who got the mtor inhibitor
had much lower rates of significant
infections over the next year
how long did the the administration last
six weeks wow yeah six weeks and then i
think it was a six-month follow-up
interestingly there were three viruses i
can't remember what the third one was
there were three that had strong effects
one was influenza the other was
coronavirus wasn't covet 19 because we
didn't know about covet 19 when this was
study was happening
but i mean imagine if we'd had a drug
that you could take for six weeks and it
would reduce the likelihood of severe
outcomes and death by 50 percent
it's amazing that is so spooky timing
yeah i remember being at the it was the
gsa meeting in november when that was
announced in john's gsa a gerontological
society of america yeah again i know it
was a tangent i don't actually remember
how i got going on it but i think it's
an important lesson for
how valuable this kind of an approach
could be right if you really could
modulate the biology of aging it will
improve age-related immune function yeah
we started with
what you would do or how you would think
about it right
so i think that's an example of a
functional measure of aging that can be
done
in a reasonable time frame in a
reasonable population site the other one
that i would really
do is or think about doing a series of
clinical trials on or and certainly with
rapamycin a larger trial than what
john's doing is periodontal disease
because the endpoints are just so great
these are endpoints that any dentist can
do
in an exam
and if we have an effect there i think
it's a really
straightforward path to fda approval if
you can actually show that you're having
an effect on periodontal disease
it's interesting because you know when
we when we were first
going down this path you know we thought
about spinning out a company to look at
periodontal disease and aging i still
think i'm going to do it someday but we
talked to vc and you want another reason
why they didn't want to do this their
vcs are always looking to get to know
man these guys drive me nuts
i do want to know why they said no
because they were afraid that you
couldn't get the insurance companies to
pay for the mouth which is true right
insurance billing is done differently
than the rest of the body and i get why
that's a concern like i understand okay
that's a concern i can't believe if you
had an intervention that reversed
periodontal disease you would not be
able to figure out how to make money on
that people would pay out of pocket
there are i would say a lot of people
just crazy to me that that's why they
torpedoed this whole thing is but
anyways that's another tangent so i but
i do think periodontal disease is a
great
clinical trial endpoint because we
expect the effects to be seen relatively
quickly and it's and it's not invasive
right it's not hard for patients to
participate yeah i'm just imagining if
that were approved
you know overnight you'd have
200 million or 100 million people being
diagnosed with periodontal disease be
kind of like at one point i don't know
if you remember this i tracked this
stuff pretty closely but
at one point almost all of the top
sprinters in the world
were diagnosed with narcolepsy
because they wanted to use modafinil why
yeah because it's a performance enhancer
but that's a side note
let's talk a little bit
about
hype and snake oil yeah which are strong
ways to put it but hype is a reasonable
way to put it and closely related to
this is how people fall for hype and
snake oil and
i think that
undergirding some of that probably a
fancy way to put it is just a lack of
familiarity with
study design with understanding
absolute versus relative risk and things
like that but i retweeted a tweet of
yours a while back that
may
be worth mentioning which related to
short-lived controls could you just
describe this sure i think it's it it at
least for me
was like in retrospect so obvious when
you pointed it out it's kind of like the
doorknob in the sixth sense but you
don't notice it through the whole movie
and i'm like god there was the whole
time so could you just explain this and
we'll we'll build off of that i think
the first thing to say is this
short-lived control so falling for the
hype can happen
in different groups and so the general
public can fall for hype as it gets
presented in this field and other places
but scientists are susceptible to this
too and i think this is an example of
how scientists can fall for
i don't even know that i would say it's
hype but be misled by the way data is
presented to believe something that
isn't as strong as it seems so this
specific case refers to the fact that
you know when we do an experiment
in mice let's just start with mice for
lifespan the untreated group so in a
typical lifespan experiment you'll have
a control group and then you'll have say
your rapamycin treated or whatever
metformin whatever it is you're testing
the untreated group we kind of know
within you know some variation how long
those animals should live because lots
and lots of people have done experiments
those kinds of experiments and it
depends a bit on the the quality of care
that they get so animals that are in a
facility that
has pathogens or is dirty or they aren't
getting good care are going to live
shorter
than animals that are well cared for
that kind of makes sense so just to put
some numbers on it let's say the normal
lifespan for
black six which is the most common mouse
strain used in biomedical research is
you know somewhere around 900 days
you will see lots and lots of
experiments in the literature where the
controls live 650 days
and then the drug or whatever that was
claimed to extend lifespan extended
lifespan to 700 days so
often what happens is those experiments
where a lifespan extension is claimed
starting from short-lived controls don't
end up being reproducible and i think i
can't prove this but i think it's
because there was something about those
controls that made them sick and
whatever the intervention did
it was in that context and it doesn't
work when you try and do it in controls
that lived as long as they're supposed
to the other thing that's important to
recognize and this is why i try not to
do this it's hard not to because we've
done it even in this talk but
try to recognize that when you present
the lifespan extension as a percent
that's a numerator and a denominator and
so it's the difference between the
treatment and control group divided by
the control group if that control group
number is small
that makes the
percent effect big
so if you have short-lived controls
something that would be maybe a five
percent effect if the controls lived as
long as they were supposed to becomes a
25 effect so there's two things going on
there that i think
tend to inflate the
belief in a result when these
experiments happen with short-lived
controls and of course
two things additional to say on that you
got to actually read the paper to even
notice this and i have found that many
people who should be reading the papers
are not actually reading the papers
they're reading the abstracts which
don't show this they just show the
percent
and you have to recognize that these in
fact were short-lived controls compared
to what we would expect based on the
literature i'll give a quick plug for
peter again he has a series of blog
posts he's also done a number of
q and a's or amas related to this but
studying the studies
is worth
perusing it's worth it's worth taking a
once through as a reader if you want to
develop a greater ability to separate
signal from noise
true i shouldn't say true
real from
not real and just sloppy from cleaner
science and certainly science
communication it's worth taking a look
at can i just stop you there because i
think that's really important but it's
also really hard for people who haven't
been trained
in the field to do that i'd certainly
recommend that people try to look at the
primary literature and you know at least
to the extent that you can figure out
what's happening it's really hard though
i remember when i first started trying
to read papers in scientific journals
every other every other works like a
different language the reason why i
bring that up is
because then what do you do if you don't
have that technical background well you
rely on
communicators to give you that
information right and i think that's
where this field in particular has
really done a terrible job because most
of what i see getting communicated to
the general public and usually it's to a
fairly educated portion of the general
public
is full of misinformation and
exaggeration and sometimes outright
falsifications that's where i really
think we need to do better i don't know
if that's unique to this field because i
know it happens in other fields as well
but i think this field is particularly
bad at that and you know i would really
like to see
the
influencers for lack of a better word
not you because
he's winking at me right now you are an
influencer but you don't typically you
know post about the latest and greatest
longevity interventions super food set
up for my friends i would really like to
see especially those who have scientific
credentials do a better job of
communicating the excitement around
what's happening and the reality of
what's happening without all of the
exaggeration and i'm going to use that
word because it's nicer than the other
word that i'm thinking of
okay
there's a lot that i want to build off
of in what you just said so
related to the short-lived controls and
i wa please call me out if i say
anything stupidly here which i i am
prone to doing when i wade into these
areas has anybody ever actually done
that to you like that was stupid well
they'll correct me they'll correct me
they may not berate me and hit me with
the rolled up newspaper but they will
say well
that's one way to put it but here's
another way to think about it because
you said it like a complete idiot my
filter's on there all right it's
important also to look at the
condition
in some cases comorbidities in the group
that is being treated right when you're
looking at percentage or absolute
changes and
what brings
this to mind for me is actually
metformin and i'm not familiar with the
literature to the extent that you would
be but i remember speaking with
someone i would certainly consider an
expert with respect to metformin
and we'd had to
spend some time together
and his perspective was
for say me that it would not make sense
for me to take metformin because if i'm
watching my diet and i am doing
resistance training and so on that the
expected value of that the delta
would not be worth
ingesting another pharmaceutical which
is part of the reason that i maybe
unfairly took it off of the the list of
candidates and i was asking you for a
second and in third place
coming back to the sort of hype
hyperbole etc
i'm not automatically putting this in
that category but it seemed like you had
a lot of good things to say about nad
precursors so why not do infusions why
not try to replenish nad let's touch on
metformin first and then we can come
back because nad we could spend two
hours on that alone okay um i don't want
to though um so metformin's really
interesting right so the reason why i
wouldn't probably put it at the top of
the list i know i wouldn't put at the
top of the list in dogs is in mice
metformin doesn't actually
reproducibly extend lifespan it depends
on the strain background it does seem to
work in a very short-lived cancer-prone
strain but outside of that not really so
it's not in the same
category of things like rapamycin or a
carbos or things that robustly and
reproducibly extend lifespan and in
people
this is where the data is kind of
interesting because definitely if you're
diabetic or metabolically compromised
you get a mortality benefit from
metformin
there is a hint at least in certain
populations that
diabetics taking metformin may
have a mortality benefit compared to
non-diabetics not taking metformin
that's kind of the best argument from a
mortality perspective in terms of
testing metformin in people
my intuition aligns very well with what
you described in that
i don't
personally think there's a high
likelihood that metformin is going to be
beneficial for people who are
not metabolically compromised and you
know eat a relatively good diet and are
active
we have a friend joining us molly came
over
so that's my that that's my feeling the
other thing is there is there have been
a couple of reports another one just
recently you know suggestive i would not
say it's rock solid but suggestive that
metformin may actually counteract some
of the benefits of resistance training
so that's another reason why i wouldn't
for myself really consider taking
metformin
all right
okay metformin check nad or nad
precursor nad's super complicated so the
first thing is nad itself
in order to take nad you either have to
do it as an infusion or apparently i've
heard you can inject it into your butt
i've never done that boof boofing nad so
i think dot com votes get a 10 discount
discount code is that is that fair i
don't get it
promo code
i get a half percent profit share but
don't don't read the fine print so
that's not for me but also i think it's
you know there is a question even
whether or not intravenous nad or nad
injections give you a real boost in
bioavailable nad in cells and tissues
the same thing can be said about the nad
precursors so
you know you alluded to this that it's
not clear how stable they are and and
you know there have been questions
around the companies that are selling
them
even the people in the field who are
supposed to be the experts on these
molecules and there are two that are
commonly
talked about and studied nicotinamide
riboside and nicotinamide mononucleotide
even the people who are supposed to be
experts in those molecules
sorry yeah
nr because people might write right now
nr
versus nmn
even the experts can't agree with each
other about them and you know one side
will say the other one's not
bioavailable the other side will say the
other one you know it's it's like come
on guys this is a solvable problem
scientifically
so that gives me some some skepticism
the other thing is you know we tried
some experiments in my lab with both nr
and nmn and we never got it to work i
know other people do but it does make me
think that there are
experimental details that are important
like
do you have to keep it in the
refrigerator can it be in the mouse food
for 24 hours before you give it to them
right are there some things
that we don't understand about why it
works sometimes and why it doesn't work
other times that need to be figured out
and then i think there are still
questions about are they useful and
that's a different question right and
again the data is mixed so you know
there was one paper that had a
short-lived control problem where
nicotinamide riboside was claimed to
extend lifespan the interventions
testing program tried to reproduce that
and they couldn't at any of the three
sites so does nr extend lifespan and
mice maybe but probably not nobody's
done an nmn experiment yet that i know
of for lifespan and mice
so
it's kind of striking how much attention
these molecules have gotten
when the actual body of evidence i
wouldn't say it's weak i mean there is
smoke there there's a lot of smoke there
but it's not clear that there's much
fire yet and so i'm waiting to see how
it plays out
next up for
examination resveratrol oh god
and this might be a helpful place also
because people who have attempted to
educate themselves let's just assume
that they're not going into studies
in the
fields of
aging
longevity
extending health span or lifespan are
probably going to come across the
sirtuins yeah so if maybe you want to
tackle those two
so i'll start with sirtuins so sirtuins
are a family of proteins that are named
after
sir2 and that's a yeast protein so this
was first discovered in budding yeast
sirtuins are
what are called this is a little bit of
a technical term they're called nad
dependent
deacetylases there are a couple of other
activities that they can do as well but
the nad dependent part is the important
part here and this ties back into the
nad precursors and what this means is
that their activity
uses nad and unlike many of the
reactions the metabolic reactions that
nad is used for sirtuins consume nad so
what most metabolic reactions do is they
take nad the oxidized form and convert
it to nadh the reduced form and that can
happen in a cycle right that's easy
sirtuins actually break down nad so you
actually lose nad
when sirtuins are active and they
require nad and this gets back to the
decline in nad activity with age
as nad levels go down the prediction is
that the activity of sirtuins go down
and sirtuins do a whole bunch of stuff
it's way beyond the scope of this
conversation to try to talk about what
people think they know about what
strategies do but sirtuins got very
popular in the aging field and that
really goes back to my graduate work so
the first project i had in lenny's lab
was studying the yeast certu at that
point we didn't know what it did we
didn't know what the activity was and we
had a reason to think it might be
involved in aging and so my first
project was to over express sir too so i
just put a second copy of the gene into
the cell
and we found mitch mcveigh and i did
this he was a graduate student at the
same time we found that that was enough
to extend lifespan
that's how sirtuins got started in the
aging field and i'm not sure whether i
deserve credit or blame for this
i'm pretty sure i deserve both um you
mean i should thank you for learning
beautifully if i drink more red wine
i'll live life there would be no
conversations around sirtuins and aging
i don't think if that experiment hadn't
been done in any case what really got
people interested though was when heidi
tissenbaum who was a postdoc in the lab
showed that if you took the the worm
version this is c elegans which we we
touched on earlier it took the worm
version of sir two which is called sir
2.1 and over expressed in worms you
could extend lifespan and then other
people showed the same thing in flies
and at that point i think everybody got
excited that this may be a new family
of enzymes that affect aging and
this might tie into a topic that you
might want to talk about they affect
the epigenome the histone diacetylases
are our epigenetic histone acetylation
is an epigenetic mark which is also
interesting in the context of aging so
so that's why everybody got excited and
then
i don't know how many
hundreds of millions of dollars have
been spent trying to prove
that the mammalian sirtuins and there
are seven of them
cert one through seven or two and one
through seven
are important regulators of aging and
there's one case maybe cert six
maybe is important for lifespan the
others have just completely fallen flat
so that's why i think there are some
people who are very dismissive of
sirtuins and i don't i'm not in that
camp certuans play really important role
in biology and they actually
some of them function in the same
network as mtor
my view is they just don't seem to be
very good nodes in that network for
having the effects that we want on
longevity but it is sort of striking how
the entire field or a big chunk of the
field was led down this path of sirtuins
being the center of the universe and
there was never ever
evidence to support that and i think
most people have kind of moved on but
they still get a lot of resources put
towards them so that's sirtuins
i also wonder just a quick side note and
then we'll get to resveratrol how much
of that mimetic spread and
momentum was because sirtuins are easy
this is going to sound stupid but easy
to say compared to a lot of the terms
that we've used in this there's no right
answer it's just it's easy for a lay
audience and for people to repeat yeah
anyway it's an interesting idea i don't
yeah i don't know i mean the question of
why some ideas you know catch on and
take over is fascinating and that
happens in science all the time i do
absolutely remember meetings though
where it was like you know fifty percent
certain talk that has stopped but for a
while that was the case okay but i do
wanna say like i haven't i have not
given up on sirtuins as therapeutic
targets for aging i just haven't seen
anything yet that makes me convinced
that that's a useful strategy but they
probably are therapeutic targets for
something i mean they do play important
roles in in biology i don't want to make
it sound like that
so resveratrol right
this is a complicated story so
resveratrol is of course the the
molecule from red wine that's how it
kind of got popularized and famous why
are you smiling i'm sorry i'm smiling
because it was just hilarious to me how
quickly the motivated reasoning in the
media converted it into
your
wine habit is justified not only is it
justified you should drink more red wine
yeah anyway yeah so i'm gonna digress
and you just tell me if i'm getting too
far in the weeds but i think it's useful
to go back to where this all started
right so so resveratrol has been around
forever it is a natural product
polyphenol found in the skin of grapes
that's why it ends up in wine it's also
found in other plants
but it's been studied for a long time in
pharmaceutical science and in fact i
only learned this after you know we were
working on resveratrol you know it turns
out that resveratrol has come out of
probably thousands of screens at
pharmaceutical companies for different
activities it is probably one of the
dirtiest drugs that are out there and i
don't mean that in a disparaging way
this is a technical term okay so
so a clean drug means it has one
biochemical target and one this is
promiscuous
rapamycin is an extremely clean drug
from that perspective a dirty drug
binds to a whole bunch of stuff and has
all sorts of effects right so it's hard
to predict and it turns out resveratrol
is extremely dirty and it's come out of
lots and lots of pharmaceutical company
screens to the point where they just
ignore it right if it comes out so this
has been studied extensively how this
got into the aging community was a study
done
by david sinclair's lab i think it was
published in 2003 where they reported
that resveratrol was an activator of
sirtuins and specifically yeast sir two
and mammalian sir t1 so two specific
sirtuins i think they looked at in that
paper
and they reported that resveratrol could
increase lifespan in yeast i mean it was
published in nature which is one of the
one of the high profile journals but
that didn't get the attention of the
media the subsequent study
where they showed that mice on a
high-fat diet
lived longer if they were given
resveratrol was the one that started
sort of the media firestorm and so david
started a company called certris again
playing on the sirtuin brand and they
were very successful at marketing the
story
that resveratrol was an activator of
sirtuins we would test other drugs like
resveratrol to activate sirtuins and we
would have effects on longevity and
healthspan that was the story there and
then the fact that resveratrols in red
wine i mean gasoline on the fire
if i was going to pick a drug that i
wanted to sell as my longevity drug it's
hard to pick one better than the one
that is found in red wine
that's a great story so anyways
so how do we get from that to where we
are today which is pretty much nobody's
paying attention to resveratrol in the
field in fact it's funny because i i was
at the american aging association annual
meeting just last month
and uh somebody asked me about
resveratrol and i looked in the the
abstract booklet and the term was there
once so one person had a poster on
resveratrol and the phrase was the
resveratrol treated animals were no
different than the controls so i think
the field has moved on
so how do we get from there to here
so my piece in this story which is a
small piece in the story but at about
the time
between when the yeast paper came out
and the mouse paper came out brian
kennedy and i were
testing a hypothesis that caloric
restriction was working through sir two
so specifically in yeast that was sort
of the model that had been proposed and
we were testing that and we had some
evidence that argued against that we
could show that we could get rid of sir
two and still get lifespan extension
from caloric restriction and we had read
david's paper and we thought this would
be a really good tool we're using
resveratrol to test this a little bit
more because we could use it as a drug
to activate sir two and see what happens
if we combine that with caloric
restriction so that was my only ratio
just because the iv injection this is
just cells on a plate yeah i see oh yes
so this is really easy really simplistic
and so we tried that and
we could not get resveratrol to do
anything to the east like they didn't
live shorter they didn't live longer we
tried all sorts of doses we tried you
know
keeping the plates in the dark and we
tried everything we could think of
talked to david tried to get an
explanation from him we couldn't get it
to work so then we were started asking
so why can't we reproduce this lifespan
extension and i will say the lifespan
extension that was reported in that
first paper was huge i mean it was like
70
which is
a big number with normal lift controls
like it's hard to ima it was hard for me
to imagine that that was wrong because
you can't be wrong by accident by that
much the statistical likelihood that you
would be wrong by that much is very low
so we started trying to figure out why
couldn't we reproduce this and so we did
a whole bunch of painstaking biochemical
experiments where we finally figured out
that resveratrol was not activating sir
two in the cells
that's called in vivo but it could
activate sir two and sir t1 towards a
very short peptide and this turns out to
be the peptide that they used in that
first paper where they put uh this is
again a little technically complicated
but they basically put a chemical group
on the end of the peptide and it was
that chemical group that changed the
conformation so that
cert ii could be activated towards
resveratrol now
no proteins in our body have that
specific chemical group on them
so that explained to us why resveratrol
was not activating sir two and extending
lifespan in yeast i still can't explain
how they got the lifespan extension that
they reported i'm not even going to try
but that explained to us why we couldn't
see anything in yeast it also left open
the formal possibility that maybe there
are some proteins in the cell
that
looked sort of structurally like this
chemical moiety and that resveratrol
could activate certain storage was that
word you used moiety moiety yeah is that
yiddish a group i don't know
it's a it's a word i learned you know at
some point in graduate school it's a
chemical structure
yeah so um lawyers number with me
recently
i think we were pretty
appropriate in the title of pixel we
said resveratrol is a substrate-specific
activator of sirtuins it just turns out
the only substrate we could find was
this artificial one that only works in a
test tube but maybe it works in some
cells sometimes so there have been a lot
of back and forth arguments back and
forth i was like i'm done i want nothing
to do with resveratrol after this but
other people argued about it but the one
thing i will say so so and again it's
hard to close the door once people
believe that something is true it takes
a long time to convince the field that
that is not the case i think we're there
now so there was a meta analysis done
relatively recently
looking at
most i won't say all
but most of the published studies where
resveratrol has ever been tested and
it's the largest database of aging
experiments that's out there and ask the
question if we look across all the
organisms and all the experiments what
is the consensus and the consensus is no
effect so
every experiment that's in this database
you look at the effect of resveratrol
and it's zero and that's like dozens
maybe hundreds of experiments so i think
the story is told
and yet
i really didn't want to call david out
on your podcast but i'm gonna call this
one thing out he still posts about
resveratrol and i'm like look man
i would stop if i was you this is done
now the other thing i'll say
resveratrol does have biological
activities like i mentioned it is a
dirty drug and there are
epidemiological studies there aren't any
of them that are particularly good as in
my view but there are epidemiological
studies that suggest that sure people
who do mega dosing of resveratrol may
have some benefits probably not lifespan
but maybe for cardiovascular disease or
something like that so i'm not saying
resveratrol isn't going to do anything
i'm saying it seems clear to me that it
doesn't affect the biology of aging
robustly and maybe not at all
let me add a layperson's
resveratrol story this will be very
short but i became somewhat interested
in resveratrol in 2008 when i was
initially working on
the four-hour body long time ago back
when i had hair and
i became very interested primarily in
the potential endurance or purported
endurance enhancing effects yeah and i
have
terrible terrible endurance i will i
will leave it at that i have some funny
stories in the 4-hour body related to
working with sports scientists who did
muscle biopsies and looked at my like
citrate synthase and so on it's it's
quite funny it turns out that i'm kind
of below homer simpson in a number of
them
tragic funny that kind of like crying
clown kind of funny but
the
entire
process of of reading into risk virtual
led me to start using it and two things
how many bottles a day
i was red wine oh no no
cases right how many cases of red wine
i ended up purchasing a supplement and
ended up consuming most of each bottle
each day i mean just because of the
dosing regimen involved there were two
things that came of it number one and i
can't remember the name of this i did
put it somewhere on my blog or in the
book but there was some type of filler
used in the capsules that also had a
secondary use
as a
laxative so i very unfortunately ended
up feeling like i was preparing for a
colonoscopy it was terrible
secondly once i figured that out and
modified the supplier i was tracking
loosely
conversations on something that was
called
it was either the 500 club or the 500
forum something like that and it was a
bulletin board for people who had been
taking
500 milligrams per day i want to say of
trans
and
i
after a few
weeks somewhere between week three and
week eight
developed and this is anecdote obviously
plural of anecdote does not equal
data or study but i developed incredible
joint pain in my elbows and
it was the only
new variable that i could pick out in my
regimen and went into the forums and
found a lot of examples of people
complaining
yeah anyway just as a side note also to
underscore that you don't always get a
biological free lunch with unlimited
upside and no downside you never do
right i mean i think that's something
that's important to appreciate right
there are always anything you do in a
complex biological system and human
beings are extremely complex is going to
have unanticipated consequences now it
may be possible that you could get a
longevity intervention that that has no
significant side effects but i'm
and i guess depends on what you mean by
significance yeah i'm skeptical
resistance training i'm skeptical yeah
right well there are a lot of side
effects to resistance training my legs
are sore right now
in terms of taxes to be paid
seems reasonable so uh but yeah i mean i
think you know again that's the
challenge with these supplements and i
and like i mentioned this paper was
published in 2003 so 20 years it's taken
to clean this mess up and it's still not
cleaned up and there are still a lot of
people like i'm sure i will get some
hate mail from saying what i said about
resveratrol although i think everything
i said is accurate in terms of the data
there are lots of people who
passionately believe in resveratrol and
you know
the data are what they are not going to
apologize
it seems like we could almost think of
these interventions as a i'm going to
try to imitate
peter t the best of my ability and pull
out my mckinsey hat which i never worked
for mckinsey but let's say we had a two
by two matrix they gave you a hat
and you have sort of
doesn't work does no harm does work
does no harm then you have doesn't work
does harm does work does harm does that
make sense like you could yeah in other
words you you could you could take
something that has no downside in which
case fine if it does no harm but um
there are often as you pointed out if
not most of the time these trade-offs
and or unintended side effects and take
intravenous nad as an example so i did
just a curiosity because a number of
high-level athletes were kind of
badgering me about nad and and claiming
all these benefits i was like okay fine
i'll do a series of say five infusions
these iv sessions and for anyone who
hasn't experienced this i think it's a
fair description if you imagine
when you are getting not necessarily a
push but an iv drip with nad
it feels to me like a combination of
being
hyper
caffeinated
in the sense that you get that creepy
crawly sort of fidgety
tweaker feeling
but without any of the upside
and then you feel like you have andre
the giant sitting on your chest like
there is a pressure and sort of
smothering feeling
and i observe this in everyone in the
room it wasn't just me i mean it is a
highly it can be a highly highly highly
uncomfortable experience and the reason
i bring this up is not to say people
should never do it it's just like okay
there are costs
and that should be it seems part of the
calculus yeah and i i would agree with
that completely and i and and this is
something i try to communicate right is
that we don't know all the costs and
there could also be unanticipated
benefits to lots sure but i think trying
to take an open-minded view of
the potential side effects actual side
effects potential reward in all things
is important and i actually think this
is really i mean this also ties into
i think one of the challenges we face in
the field of trying to bring geroscience
or aging biology mainstream from a
clinical perspective is most physicians
are trained to do no harm and not to
treat people who aren't sick
and i understand the rationale for that
but in the context of aging
we know exactly what the consequence is
well maybe not exactly everybody
experiences different problems but we
know ultimately what the consequence is
going to be of doing nothing so but that
never gets taken into the equation right
of of what is the risk reward
considering that there's a risk of doing
nothing there is an absolutely a huge
risk of doing nothing to maintain our
health as we get older
but people don't think of it that way
and physicians don't think of it that
way and so we have to start to change
that mindset to weigh that into the
equation sure rapamycin may have some
low level of risk but there's the
possibility that it is going to increase
your healthy lifespan by 10
how much risk are you willing to
tolerate
you ask the average person they in their
head can do that
maybe to some extent analysis but a
physician immediately most physicians i
shouldn't say this it's a generalization
but many are very resistant to the idea
of doing anything for somebody who's not
sick to keep them well and we have to
change that
do you think it's a liability issue and
therefore it could be fixed with some
degree of
change with respect to
i don't know how you would catalyze it
but sort of defensive medicine baby yeah
so i think that could be part of it i
don't think most positions and again i
guess these are just conversations i've
had so i this is my impression but i
don't think most physicians at least
think of it that way i think it really
comes back more to the training that
they receive the
concept that you
do no harm which i mean i understand
that concept but
they're never trained to think about
what the harm of doing nothing might be
and i think there is no
component of a medical school curriculum
yet that educates
medical students
on
the fact that the biology of aging is
modifiable and that's a relatively new
concept for a long time everybody
thought you couldn't do anything about
it i mean everybody recognizes that age
is the greatest risk factor for cancer
heart disease kidney disease you know go
down the list there's like 20 of them
but everybody thought you couldn't do
anything about it
now you
can or at least
we're close
we know we can modify aging biology in
laboratory animals so
starting to get that training will i
think change the mindset i'm sure there
is a liability component where
physicians are hesitant to do anything
that will risk malpractice i actually
think that's probably a pretty tractable
problem i think
as people become more educated in this
area insurers will recognize that from a
cost perspective if you can keep people
from getting sick that probably is
economically more viable than
paying tens of thousands of dollars for
the last three days or eight weeks or
whatever of life right
let me if i may
zoom out a little bit look at your i
want to take a closer look at
science overall this is going to sound
strange to put it that way but also
something that that strikes me as we're
talking which is
and i have a note in front of me of
course
but
you do not seem tell me if i'm off here
you do not seem to have an aversion
to
conducting studies that fail to
replicate or
turn out with
let's write terminology like a null
effect and i want you to correct my
terminology but there is a
positive publication
bias
in science yeah and
i'd love for you to just maybe speak to
how you think about science
and the purpose of science what it can
and cannot do maybe the way people get
confused by it because it's the type of
work that you're describing and that
you've done
is so so important and if people are
afraid of rejection whether that's by
peers or by journals
so they go after kind of the shiny new
object hoping to show a huge amplitude
of effect with the new intervention
that has all sorts of negative
implications so anyway that's a lot of
talking i'll start to try to address
that i think there are many there's a
lot to potentially unpack there but i
think one way to think about this and
you know this is something that i have
thought a lot about throughout my career
and especially as i become more senior
and i'm training people and my view is
especially in biology but i think this
is true in almost every scientific
discipline that
our goal should be to
develop the best model that we can for
whatever it is that we're studying right
that could be a biochemical pathway or
it could be a model of aging right or
usually it's going to be somewhere in
between the best model that we can to
explain the data that we've got at that
time
and then what we should do is we should
ask okay
where are the weaknesses here where are
the places that we have less certainty
and can we design an experiment to break
the model so the first thing to
recognize i'm sort of joking i'm not
joking but i say it in a little bit of a
harsh way but the first thing i tell
everybody in my lab when they come to
the lab when they're they're trying to
think about a project and what's going
on i'm like your model's wrong you deal
with it
your model is an imperfect
representation of reality now go figure
out where it's wrong and i think that's
exactly the way we should be doing
science if we really want to make the
most progress because the only way
you're going to get closer to reality is
if you figure out where the model
doesn't fit
so that is the way i train everybody in
my lab to approach their research and to
be skeptical of what they believe and i
think that is i was going to say the
right way but i don't want to i don't
want to make it have a moral connotation
to it i think it's the approach to
science that is most likely to get us to
where we want to be which is to
understand whatever it is that we're
studying
the problem that i see is
the reward structure
in
certainly biomedical research is set up
to do the opposite of that which is to
decide what the answer is and go do
experiments to prove the answer and i
have seen
over and over and over in my career
people who ignore
data that doesn't fit their model
because well the model's right
and it's much easier to publish your
paper in high impact journals if you
only show the data that fits your model
i mean it's just a fact
and so i have real concerns that that's
partly why the field gets led astray
with things like resveratrol because
people ignored the data that didn't fit
the model and they only published or
what sometimes happened is people will
do the experiment 10 times nine times it
won't work they'll publish the one time
that it does that's a version of
ignoring the data that doesn't fit the
model that is rampant in science i mean
i hate to say it but it is everywhere
and in fact
as i've alluded to the reward structure
encourages that and people who do that
tend to be successful in terms of
scientific publications and getting
grants and then they train their
postdocs and graduate students to
approach science that way so i think
that's one of the big problems in in
science right now i don't have a great
solution i wish i did
and i also want to say i i said i don't
want to make this about a moral sort of
thing like it's right or wrong i
honestly don't think that
many maybe most of the people who do
that recognize what they're doing i
think that's the way they've been
trained but i think it's a problem and i
think it does tend to lead us down wrong
roads and leads to a lot of waste and
maybe that's part of the
irreproducibility
problems that keep cropping up right
that everybody knows about so that's one
thought that i have around that approach
and i do have to say i've also thought
of this i can't say that i'm necessarily
doing the people in my lab a favor by
training them to do that kind of science
because it makes it harder makes it
harder to be successful
who are some scientists and this is
always a tricky question because people
inevitably interviewees will say oh i
just thought of another three or four or
five or ten people i should have
mentioned but
if you were to just off the cuff name a
few researchers scientists whatever
category you might want to put them in
who you find interesting to follow or
who other folks might find interesting
to follow
who comes to mind i think one of the
things that will
impact this is exactly what we were just
talking about people who do what i
consider very high quality work and so i
would say one of my long time
collaborators who's also one of my best
friends his name is brian kennedy he
leads the aging research institute at
national university singapore very broad
view of aging i think somewhat you know
similar to me i would say have a pretty
broad view of the field and does you
know great work in everything from
purely basic all the way through to now
doing stuff in clinical world and brunei
at stanford is another person who is
absolutely fantastic does very sort of
cutting-edge research on
all sorts of stuff but particularly in
the area of stem cell biology and
regeneration how do you spell her last
name
b-r-u-n-e-t
yushin su at colombia who i mentioned
earlier is doing this rapamycin study of
ovarian function and she's sort of
unique so she did a lot of work with
near bars of life on genetic
associations with longevity but but she
was one of the few people who actually
tried to take a functional approach to
that and go beyond just figuring out
okay this gene seems to be correlated
with say centenarians
to look at the specific variant and try
to figure out functionally what is that
variant doing and she you know she's
really a master at adopting the very
most cutting-edge technologies and
applying them
fantastic thank you
i will look into
all of those and we'll put those in the
show notes at
team.blog
podcast
as well
matt there are a million other things we
could talk about but we've been going
now for almost two and a half hours i
think this is probably a good place to
begin to
wind down and if people would like to
hear more of these types of
conversations about
i'm still struggling to use the right
term what would you say we need to come
up with a word it's hard to know i mean
i like gero science but it's a little
too techy maybe but i think it does
capture like i said that interface
between aging biology and what we've
been trained to care about which is
disease so i like that term and i think
it fits um so i'm going to go with
so if you'd like to hear
more conversations like this
perhaps around two with matt at some
point related to jarrah science and so
on because there is so much noise
there's so much noise so much [ __ ]
i went to get some backup batteries for
this recording device and he pulled up
this magazine that was staring in the
face on the newsstand you're like i
can't go 20 steps without something like
this staring me in the face
and it was just some nonsense that had
been thrown together to sell magazines
if you'd like to hear more please let me
know on twitter matt is there anything
else you would like to say point people
to in terms of
projects or anything else requests of
the audience you'd like to make anything
at all yeah two things so one if you
have a dog and you're not part of the
dog aging project please go to the
website
dogagingproject.org and nominate your
dog to participate we are absolutely
still looking to enroll dogs both in the
pack and in the clinical trial the thing
i want to say is you know i don't want
to end on the sort of there's so much
noise and so much hype it is true
there's also a ton of reason to be super
excited about the biology in this field
and there is so much fantastic work
happening in the field and exciting and
you know some of the interventions that
we talked about new stuff that people
are discovering around
stem cell function and circulating
factors and senescent cells that i think
are targetable not only the new science
but also potential therapeutics and then
you know some potential moonshots so we
didn't talk about epigenetic
reprogramming and that is a whole topic
on its own there is a lot of noise and
misinformation and
exaggeration around epigenetic
reprogramming but it's also an area that
i think has a lot of promise
so i want to leave your listeners with
the knowledge that there is a lot to be
optimistic about and i know it's hard
sometimes to separate the noise from the
signal there's a lot of signal here too
and i would love to come back and do a
deep dive on the signal at some point
absolutely ooh cliffhanger oh the car
literally half off epigenetic
reprogramming we'll have to wait for
round two folks so let us know
if you care say something on twitter
i've never said that before in my life
all right people can find you dr matt
caberline on
cablelinelab.org
on twitter m caberline i'm going to
spell that m-k-a-e-b-e-r-l-e-i-n
we will link to everything in the show
notes so that people can find it all in
one place at team dot blog slash podcast
thank you matt for taking the time thank
you really enjoyed it really enjoyed it
i appreciate you putting up with all of
my my plotting around and grasping for
things in the dark trying to figure out
terminology i really took a ton of notes
as you can see right in front of me and
everybody out there
until next time be a little kinder than
necessary and as always thank you for
tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to tim
dot blog friday type that into your
browser tim dot blog slash
friday drop in your email and you'll get
the very next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt what on earth is
element it is a delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix i've stocked up on
boxes and boxes of this it was one of
the first things that i bought
when i saw copic coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb or paleo diet or if you
drink a ton of water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise mountain biking
etc another application if you've ever
struggled to feel good on keto low carb
or paleo it's most likely because even
if you're consciously consuming
electrolytes you're just not getting
enough and it relates to a bunch of
stuff like a hormone called aldosterone
blah blah blah when insulin is low but
suffice to say this is where element
again spelled lmnt can help my favorite
flavor by far is citrus salt which is a
side note you can also use to make a
kick-ass no sugar margarita but for
special occasions obviously you're
probably already familiar with one of
the names behind it rob wolf r-o-b-b rob
wolf who is a former research biochemist
and two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch that's how it got started his
brazilian jiu-jitsu coaches turned him
onto electrolytes as a performance
enhancer things clicked and bam company
was born so if you're on a low carb diet
or fasting electrolytes play a key role
in relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring all that's garbage
unneeded there's none of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be by one of my favorite
athlete friends three navy seal teams as
prescribed by their master chief marine
units fbi sniper teams at least five nfl
teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it element will give you your money
back no questions asked they have
extremely low return rates for a limited
time you can get a free element sample
pack with any purchase it's the perfect
way to try all of their flavors or if
you're feeling generous sharing with a
friend who might enjoy this special
offer is available here at this link
drinklmnt.comtim
that's drink element again drink lmnt
dot com slash tip
this episode is brought to you by levels
very excited about this one i wrote
about the health benefits of using
continuous glucose monitors cgm's more
than 10 years ago in the four hour body
and at that time cgms were horribly
primitive and hard to use super painful
levels has now made this technology and
the insights that come from it easy and
available to everyone putting in the
sensors everything about it is smooth
easy i found it completely painless and
i started tracking my glucose way back
in the day to learn more about what i
should and shouldn't be eating keeping
my blood sugar stable is critical to my
daily and long-term health and
performance goals with levels you can
see how different foods affect your
health with real-time feedback poor
glucose control which you don't want is
associated with a number of chronic
conditions not just diabetes but also
alzheimer's and heart disease can impact
your mood certainly affects my mood
energy levels right that work in the
afternoon that dip that you feel for
instance that's just one example and
weight management and we all respond
differently sometimes a little bit
sometimes vastly differently even to the
same foods so one type of carbohydrate
that my body might process well let's
say that's fruit or rice or sweet potato
your body might not the levels app
interprets your glucose data and
provides a simple score after you eat a
meal so you can see how different foods
affect you and then develop a
personalized diet that's right for you
and your goals seeing this data in real
time at least for me and for so many
others who use levels is a really
powerful behavioral change mechanism and
many of the guests on the podcast have
talked about this marco kenora famous
chef used levels to determine that say
walking for him just a few hundred steps
after a meal significantly affected his
glucose levels
levels is backed by a world-class team
and group of advisors including names
you've likely heard before including
repeat podcast guest dr dom d'agostino
and many others if you're interested in
learning more about levels and trying a
cgm yourself
learn all about it go to levels dot link
slash tim that's levels dot link slash
tim i'll spell it out l e v e l s dot l
i n k slash tim check them out today
i highly encourage you to consider
getting this data on your own personal
responses to the food that you eat the
food that maybe you shouldn't eat the
food that you might want to eat more of
all of these things you can learn and
that is at levels dot link slash tim you
can also find the link in this episode's
description
[Applause]
you